advice good morning to all of you thank
you for uh coming
um so just to um start us off um Jillian
Cooper if I can come to you
um first
um as we start to go into this winter
what is the current state of the kind of
consumer body around energy bills from
what you've been seeing we've been
hearing concerns around
self-disconnection we're talking about
prepayment meters debt levels uh
presumably there's going to be a legacy
of the energy crisis that we'll need to
think about what does that look like at
the moment
so 2022 was a year unlike any other
we've seen because we had a cost of
living crisis go from bad to worse at
citizens advice we were breaking
unwelcome records pretty much every
month last year
um with regard to the number of people
we were helping who were in crisis
situations
um in December it was more than three
people every minute with Crisis Support
and that's food vouchers fuel vouchers
other charitable Aid the number of
people we helped who were struggling to
afford their energy bills is completely
unprecedented we also saw a record rise
in December of the number of people who
couldn't afford to top up their
prepayment meter
um it was more than what we'd seen in
the previous 10 years combined
and to us we think that suggested the
government support package has not been
enough to keep people's Heating and
lights on and we think that low-income
households are are paying the price for
a broken energy Market here and where
that has sort of had a real impact is
people who pay by prepay it has up until
this point being a payment method that
has functioned pretty well for millions
of households but it's now much much
riskier because of the the sort of
sky-high energy bills and cost of living
crisis and whilst people have valued the
control it's given them over how much
they spend on energy
it has it has become a crisis for quite
a number of households and we published
a report earlier this month that showed
that millions of people had had
disconnected from their prepayment meter
at least once
um once a year and a number of very
vulnerable households were disconnecting
regularly and for extended periods of
time and that included people who
disabled people or people with a
long-term health condition so we've
called for a temporary a moratorium on
the forced installation of prepayment
meters until we can and put some new
Protections in place to support people
who are struggling to afford their
energy bills thank you and and Peter
Smith does does that sound right from
from your perspective are those the
types of customers we need to think
about additional support for people on
low-income vulnerable households
households of disability requirements
prepayment meter customers is that is
that right yeah I think that that sounds
like a very familiar picture we're a
small advice provider in um in in
contrast to Citizens advice but we've
seen record numbers of people coming to
us asking for support and the
devastating impact this winter has been
really acute
um just to say something briefly about
the agencies that are there to support
those households I think they're facing
unprecedented challenges
um really really struggling with
increased demand for services a lack of
tools in the toolkit in terms of what we
can do to support those households
um the um the the other thing I would
observe is an increased concern from
other statutory bodies that haven't
historically interfaced on energy issues
particularly Fire and Rescue Services
are reporting real huge increase in
instances of people doing unsafe things
in their home in a desperate attempt to
keep warm and that's having a big impact
on their thinking about responding to
the wider cost of living crisis in terms
of the groups you've highlighted you I
think that those are the main groups the
the real
um weakness in our current approach to
targeting is not being able to support
those households that live on the lowest
incomes but don't claim any means-tested
benefits and and how that then over
um intersects with other vulnerabilities
like medical conditions Etc and those
the most vulnerable people that are
still waiting for a significant amount
of support to get through this situation
and that presumably is because energy
companies or the government can't easily
just pull up a list of those customers
and send help to them right we do have
the Priority Services registered and
we've been urging the government to look
at that as a way of targeting more
support towards those households but
unfortunately those Priority Services
registers haven't been kept up to date
and there hasn't been as much proactive
work by energy supplies as there have
been for Network companies for example
who have been using those as more active
tools to support customers her pinchback
is that right energy suppliers haven't
been keeping their priority lists up to
date I think the thing that's missing in
what Junior MP so that I'd Echo much of
what they said I don't think anyone is
pretending that there isn't an energy
crisis on and that bills aren't except
in the eye and that people aren't
struggling is is the scale of it so in
our call centers cause about 300 on
previous years and the requests for
additional support are up 300 too and
what that indicates is we've got many
more houses moving into what has been
considered vulnerability previously at
PACE who
and all households who are not
indicating to us that they're vulnerable
so I think from the suppliers there's an
acceptance that more needs to be done in
the vulnerability space and we're
working actively with the consumer
groups and governments do that but I
would say that this is a much bigger
problem than just prepayment meters
vulnerable customers
um bills if they were double what they
were 18 months ago and we've got about
12 million households which is about 40
of customers spending more than 10 on
energy that's the previous definition of
fuel poverty so I think we need to look
at targeted support but we also need to
look at this as an affordability crisis
across the piece and how that intersects
with wider cost of living and we're up
for having those conversations but I
don't think it is as simple as just
looking at the Priority Services to
register I think this is still a really
big problem how do we fix that I mean
you say you're working with government
on it how do we find those customers
that need help
so and I mean it'll be interesting to
hear from Pete and June on this too but
what we have done we've been flagging
with government the risks around
vulnerability and prepayment customers I
think before I went on maternity leave
so for two years now
um and then since the Autumn we've been
asking for specific meetings on these
issues in particular
ly
have you had those meetings we have so
we had a meeting with the minister last
week
um we called for it before Christmas
um we've put in some proposals that we
were working through with consumer
groups with off Gem and the minister so
they're draft at this stage I've also
shared them with committee Clark so you
know that I'm not just making this up so
you can have a look yourself in in draft
form
um the kinds of things we're talking
about doing is a enforcing the existing
license conditions it's worth saying
it's 250 page supplier license the steps
that should be taken to get to the kind
of prepayments install Point are
extensive similarly with identifying
vulnerable customers if rules are being
broken we want to know about them they
should be enforced I think there's a
question about off-gem capacity there
that we have raised with government and
then on top of that we're proposing
um kind of codifying and setting out
some principles that go further than the
license for how we treat vulnerable and
prepayment customers that's what's up
for discussion with government and then
we're calling on more support so the
energy price guarantee is due to
basically be raised in April we think
that that should be fixed to 2500 pounds
for the rest of the year there's an
under spend on that program against what
was budgeted because gas prices have
fallen we're also calling like the
consumer groups for some kind of
targeted support in addition to that so
we're very up for conversations about
things like social terrorists and we've
written to the chancellor to call for
the kind of long-term picture on bills
to be sorted by investing in green
infrastructure but also in Energy
Efficiency and doing some things in vit
to make that easier so
I suppose the short answer this is we're
doing it lots behind the scenes and as
much as we think that we can given the
debt burden on the sector to try and
help our customers without saying at all
that if rules are being broken that's
excusable I just I check and I
understood correctly so you represent
energy suppliers and you've just asked
for the regulator to be tougher with
your own companies why can't you just do
the job properly in the first place so
we expect Our member companies to be
doing their job properly in the first
place but I think what we're saying is
if the regulator or systems advice on
consumer groups the same things that the
suppliers don't see that should be
raised and sorted to give you an example
of where why there might be a gap where
the energy suppliers so quite often
people don't tell us when they're
vulnerable because they either don't
know that help exists or they're more
comfortable having these conversations
with people like Jillian and Pete so in
the past when issues have been raised
with us often it's an issue of
communication
um and then I think even when they're
talking to us quite often they don't
know exactly what the definitions of
vulnerability are so in the process of
of them
when those cases are raised with the
suppliers we often then find a reason
they were vulnerable when we previously
ruled out that they weren't that then
means that we can support them so it's
it's not to say that there isn't bad
practice going on and if there is we
want to see that Stamped Out we're a
industry that fundamentally
serves people it's an essential service
and we've got a regulator that should be
doing that job with very extensive rules
they should be enforcing but I think
it's also the case that that suppliers
can't do this on their own for reasons
that are both behavioral and and to do
with regulation okay Ruth Edwards please
thank you chair
um both citizens advice and the national
injection have raised concerns uh that
vulnerable customers are being forced
onto prepayment meters when it's not
safe or appropriate to do so and that
they're not being used as a last resort
um could you just sort of set out for us
what you're seeing on the ground in this
area
sure
um so for us there's three key groups of
people
um who are struggling to top up their
prepayment meters or at risk of being
moved on to prepaid that we're
particularly concerned about so the
first is people with physical or mental
health difficulties who will struggle to
top up
um because of affordability issues we're
also particularly concerned about
households with young children or where
there are elderly people who are more
likely to suffer Health consequences
associated with being off Supply
and the third Group which is more
challenging and I think this this is
something that Emma's members will will
need to Grapple with which is people who
are on low incomes but don't currently
have any physical or mental health
difficulties but they're unable to
afford to keep the lights on because
when you live in a cold home
you suffer consequences as a result of
that
um if we think about the sort of scale
of the challenge we've got for us so in
terms of the debt clients coming to
Citizens advice for support 50 of those
people have a negative budget which
means they cannot afford to pay for all
their essential bills at this point and
they certainly don't have any money to
to start repaying debt and so if you put
a household in that situation under
prepay they will probably disconnect
themselves and disconnect themselves
frequently
so that in our view it isn't safe for
households in that situation to to
remain on prepay or be transferred to
prepay just because of the risks and we
need to think about better ways to
safeguard these households
um and you know I accept the challenges
Emma has raised about the sort of
um the challenges suppliers are facing
with the sort of growing debt debt books
that they've got
um we agree with them this isn't this
isn't an issue that suppliers can solve
on their own but we do need to make a
decision as a society I think about
whether or not we're going to properly
Safeguard people in this situation
because energy isn't essential for life
service and you you really cannot live
without it without having really
detrimental effects to your health
and I see the citizens advice have um
said you see a number of households
forced onto pre-pay meters where the
person either requires continuous supply
of energy for health reasons or they
have accessibility needs and can't
access the Top-Up point or an illness or
disability that's exacerbated in cold
weather do you have can you give us any
sense of What proportion of customers
being forced onto prepayment meters that
would sort of entail
I think I'd struggle to give a
proportion I think we see enough case
studies and certainly other other advice
agencies such as NAA and many others are
seeing a worrying number of people who
would fall into those vulnerable
categories where it doesn't feel right
or safe for them to be on prepay so I
think this is this is where we we're
looking for off Jam's new review of
Protections in this space to to really
dig into that and try and understand the
scale of the problem because until we
know the size of the problem we can't
really work out the right solutions for
how we fix this
um
so you know I think it's really
important that off-chem carries out
proper sort of modeling of this so we we
get a good sense of the number
um
thank you Peter Smith how does that I
think we all hamstrung at the moment
because we haven't got as much reporting
data out there as they used to be by
off-chem on these issues
um but it tends to be about one
one-fifth of customers are on the
Priority Services registered for those
the reasons that you've indicated so
that gives you a sense of the sort of
scale
um of of these potential issues
thank you Emma pinchback what's the
energy markets response energy supplies
response to those those observations I
mean both the the kind of cases you're
talking about there would be breaches
and license conditions so that's the
point about there are really strong
rules around what happens in in the
process of putting someone to a
prepayment meter and so if those rules
are being broken firstly we want to know
where the cases are and they should be
raised with suppliers but secondly
there's an off-gem job for to enforce
those existing rules which we and we've
raised concerns about the regulator time
and again with this committee and
whether they're able to do that job
properly we are participating in the
after in offgen's kind of calls for
evidence around these practices have
been more requests for information
actually before Christmas so we'll do
all we can share that information I
think it's worth talking about debt
um again so we think there's about 2.5
billion pounds worth of debt sitting on
suppliers books right now
those are Figures were also getting and
supplying to government and to the
regulator of that we think bad debt
might be close to 2 billion from
independent experts we are required to
collect debt as part of the license and
so that debt has to be collected off all
Bill payers if it's not being paid and
that's one of the reasons that things
like a moratorium worry suppliers
because we have seen the consequence of
failing suppliers already on bills plus
the need to collect debt from everyone
else so
um it's it's complex for us when we look
at the market
um but that doesn't mean that we're not
sympathetic to what is a devastating
affordability problem for many
households so
um I'm not contradicting anything that
Jillian and Peter saying here I think
it's on all of us to work together to
find the solution
thank you I don't think anybody would
disagree that the regulator should be
properly resourced and should enforce
things properly but I mean we have seen
um off gem you know Publishers Market
compliance reviews on on lots of
different issues
um and we've seen energy companies you
know come out and say quite publicly
Nigel pocklington from good energy for
example off gem is overcompensating for
previous mistakes
um the founder of so energy I believe
has also said over the course of the
last three months we've you know has
again complained about off gems Market
compliance review do you think there is
a culture in the energy industry that
sees customers as Commodities rather
than people not in my experience of
working for them and
I wouldn't be in this job if I did think
that I've got as it happens I've got
family on prepayment meters who are in
some of the situations described here so
if I have a vested interest at all it's
making sure that they're treated fairly
and my experience of working directly
with supplier CEOs has been that they
have been largely Humane thinking about
these problems but they also are
required to manage debt and they are
worried given the state of the retail
sector in the UK just a reminder the
retail sector makes a negative margin in
the UK on average it was minus two
percent last year and that makes
investing in things like call centers
investing in the additional help we'd
like to provide taking on things like
you know making sure we understand
vulnerability all of those things
difficult because we don't have the
money in that bit of the industry to do
it so never in my experience of working
with the CEOs have they come across as
just you know focused on the commercials
but it is a challenging sector in the UK
and lastly the the points that you made
about so energy and and good that speaks
again to
a regulatory issue because they were
right the the problem was the
methodology of German had used to label
bad practice was basically Incorrect and
they looked at it and called it out
um and so they were unfairly named as
being poor at responding to a customer
base and so that again speaks to do they
have the right skills enough gem to do
this do they have the right capacity to
do this and I don't think any of us
would say they definitely do at the
moment okay thank you Peter I think you
wanted to come in just very briefly I
think the the number of supplier exits
that we've seen also help the regulator
in terms of enforcing the rules where
there was a plethora of very small
supplies it was probably quite difficult
to keep track on what all of them were
doing but now we've seen that
contraction again something I don't know
how many licensees there are forgive me
but something 12 15 something like that
must be a much easier task we do however
welcome their recent very recent
commitment to create a work stream
around identifying Financial
vulnerability we think that's really
important to embedding that within the
Priority Services register should help
get across some of these issues that
we've been talking about today
Cooper obviously
prepayment meters in for increased
bailiff action increased bad debt
um what citizens advisors view on that
um how could those be mitigated if such
a policy is as you're proposing as
pushed
so we we called for the moratorium
because we think the scale of bad
practice is really concerning and
there's there's a need to focus the
minds and start bringing in some proper
Solutions and some quick Solutions so
I think and it's also important to say
that if people are willingly wanting to
move over to prepay because they feel
that is the right option for them this
this wouldn't affect that in any way
this is this is the people we're
concerned about are the ones who cannot
afford to pay their energy bills and
prepay is likely to be a dangerous
solution for them because they will
regularly disconnect themselves so I
think it is right to take the time to
try and bring in new protections to
safeguard these households
um and once those protections are in
place we can look at resuming forced
forced insulations of prepay because
this isn't about sort of
stopping suppliers from using a tool to
collect debt where that is appropriate
it is about ensuring we've got the right
Protections in place to safeguard people
thank you final word to Peter the base
committee rightly highly liked the need
for a proper plan around stopping
self-disconation we agree with
short-term steps that citizens advice
are campaigning on but we need a proper
plan around looking at removing the
amount of traditional prepay we've got
out there which are badly hindering
access to government support at the
moment as well as other forms of support
looking to make sure that those prices
for prepay customers and other customers
are fairer and you know not doing more
than just monitoring the numbers on how
many people are regularly
self-disconnecting we think it's
possible for the regulator and Industry
come up with a coherent plan and really
work towards the end of
self-disconnection as a sickening part
of our Energy System thank you and can I
just politely remind members we've got
about five minutes per question if we
overrun it means less time with off gem
which I'm sure they'll be delighted
about but we would like to give them
enough time at the end um our ghost
cruise account I'm just pleased that
we're hearing that suppliers are Humane
because the ones that left because we
have heard from others who wouldn't be
characterized in that way um can I ask
some specifics around your experience of
suppliers and to kick us off are they
increasing customers direct debits even
when customers have built up large
credit balances I don't know if you come
across that Julian
do you have a lot of people contact us
because they're confused about their
energy bills we don't have we have
looked into this we don't have any firm
evidence of widespread sharp practice in
this in this area
um we do think suppliers need to do a
much better job of ensuring their
customers understand why their direct
debits are increasing I think you know
we're in a particularly unique situation
at the moment because we had a very
significant a couple of very significant
price increases in in 2022 people's
bills went up by a lot
we have also had people responding quite
significantly to those increased prices
by changing how much energy they use in
their homes a lot of people have
significantly reduced how much energy
they use because of cost issues and I
think I think there probably is a
question for industry about sort of how
quick they've been at reassessing those
direct debits are they still doing it on
a six monthly basis when actually
quarterly might make sense are they
being sufficiently flexible when they're
customers and when they come and say it
look I can't afford that increase and
they do a proper investigation at that
time rather than just sort of saying
well that's what the that's what the
algorithm tells us so I think there is
some bad practice I don't think there's
I don't think it's sort of widespread
deliberate inflating I think it's just
sort of customer service hasn't been up
to scratch did you come across that with
the balance balance problem I I find
that it's typically a case of either not
being particularly proactive about being
transparent about the methodology or or
in the case of households understanding
the um the bottom line in terms of the
quantum it's really difficult for
households we're very limited or
increasingly limited budgets to say you
know I'm going to prioritize 300 400
pounds month in my outgoings and give it
to a safari in advance I mean that's
very difficult for households and and
that speaks to a wider affordability
problem as opposed to the mechanics of
how direct debits have been calculated
okay consequence I should say briefly
consequence of some of that is that
we're seeing an increase in standard
credit customers customers that pay by
cash or by check those customers are
currently paying huge premium in the
energy Market
um due to the differentials and how the
price cap works over 250 pounds per
customer for those households that pay
by check or buy cash compared to those
direct debit customers
can I roll that up and just ask Emma
whether your your findings are that the
sufficient attention paired to people's
ability to repay debt as well as well as
sitting on ballot on credit balances
um yes that's something we obviously are
very worried about and again it's one of
the reasons that we think ppms can be a
prepayment meters can be used for Tool
um something we haven't said is that the
industry does give out a lot of
discretionary credit and one of the
reasons for that
um big debt book is that particularly
for prepayment customers the industry
generally only expects 50 of that to get
paid back ever so there's already a kind
of
a system where we think about what
additional support we can offer people
that includes prepayment plans changing
payment plans changing how they pay
discretionary credit and then an
expectation that for some households
that we may not get that credit back so
I haven't exp I mean it's something that
suppliers worry about all the time as
you'd imagine how they manage their debt
book and and how their customers are
doing
um as others have said we don't have any
evidence of sharp practice with how
direct debits work totally agree that
energy is really complex from where we
look at it we we buy ahead we hedge
ahead that's the responsible thing for
companies to do we've seen what happens
when companies don't do that
um
but Translating that to a customer
payment monthly is obviously difficult
and explaining to customers why that is
the case can be difficult so do you
perceive that there is sufficient uh
priority given to shifting people from
Legacy uh arrangements from prepayments
onto that is a sufficient attention
appeared to getting people off
prepayment what we really would like to
see and it's very much we've been
talking about dumb meters largely and
one of the tools that we would like to
be able to use more is smart meters and
particularly smart prepaid meters so one
of the commitments we have put forward
to government is that we should be doing
smart prepay first and and trying to do
that even when it's complicated for
customers as much as possible and the
reason for that is it really helps us
see when customers are changing the
behavior early it can help us see if
they're struggling with payment early if
they're changing the habits in their
households give us more information
about our households and and relatedly
help us manage the system more
efficiently to bring bills down so smart
meters for everyone critical
infrastructure could save 16 billion on
the cost of reaching at zero could help
reduce bills can help energy
infrastructure but for for prepay
customers we think they could be really
important so
um that is partly A supplier job but
there's also a call for government to
really really look at the smart meter
roll out and help help get that going
they've always kind of slightly backed
away from pushing it
um now's the time to do that yeah I
think there was about five billion
consumer worth of benefit in terms of
Shifting across the smart prepay so
massive and very clear Benefits case and
we should be getting on with that and
setting targets appropriately to deliver
that outcome quickly the um the other
quick thing I'd say is we've heard a lot
about households being automatically
switched to prepayment mode we would
like to see suppliers embrace the
opportunity to to do more in terms of
switching households temporally over to
credit mode particularly where there's
the sort of transient vulnerability
caused by being in hospital tool for
example or really really struggling to
manage your finances in a particular
month that could be a much more common
way of helping customers
and just to say that that is we firmly
agree with that and it's something that
we have asked the government and off gem
to track through this process through
this new investigation process into
prepayment because it's really important
that suppliers are able to demonstrate
where they've identified vulnerability
that they are moving that customer off
prepay because I finally just remember
you seem to be indicating that the
survivors just are struggling to have
with their resources to actually meet
these challenges what would happen to
how can we improve that situation what
has to happen I think I gave evidence in
the Autumn of 2021 as the suppliers were
beginning to fail that Autumn that we
lost 29 at the start the gas price
crisis and I said then what I'll say now
which is that I've worked in energy for
10 years and I came to retail relatively
late and I have been shocked at the lack
of attention on retail as a kind of
vibrant important part of the energy
sector and the relationship that the
suppliers have with government and the
regulator which I would characterize as
largely punitive and so
the best of the private sector is when
they can make enough money to do things
like innovate investing call centers
invest in Support over and above the
hundreds of millions they already give
but that's very very difficult in a
world where you're making negative
margins and just to give you an example
of of things that could be brilliant two
of my Supply members are now offering
heat pumps for the same price as the gas
boiler with the government grant they've
invested their resources in getting that
cost down they're training the
installers to do that
in the last few weeks we've had
suppliers aggregating load in households
to participate in flexibility trials
with the grid again those tariffs often
come at a loss for suppliers because the
structure of the market means that they
can't do that Innovation they're paying
their customers to do that they're
saving the grid money all of this stuff
this kind of innovation on top of the
customer support identifying vulnerable
people looking after our customers is
easier when you've got a market that's
functioning and the market is not
functioning and I have been saying that
pretty much since I got this job and
nothing has changed okay thank you I'm
afraid not sorry you're coming in after
bimbo so you can come in then Bim falami
thank you chair so so my question is
direct particularly at Miss pinchbeck
um
I've got a huge amount of respect for
you personally as you know I
know
um and I think you're a classic however
um relating to some of your members I
have seen this by the way my own
constituency in addition to what I'm
about to say in relation to UK
Hospitality so Emma Nichols
um has said that
many of her members as Hospitality
businesses report that suppliers
offering rates above wholesale prices
hiking standing charges demanding large
deposits and I quote the behavior of
energy suppliers over the past four
months has been nothing short of
disgraceful
so what's your sense of that do you
think she's wrong and if you don't think
she's wrong
what are you doing about it and how are
you working with your members to improve
that situation I'm glad we're talking
about non-domestic and I know you've got
a panel with Kate and others later I've
spoken to Kate in fact all of the
panelists that you're talking to later
myself
um in the job and we worked with the
business groups to call for special
support for the business sector
um when we could see that the challenges
facing them are different to the
challenges facing the retailers we will
continue to do that we've also gone to
our members and asks for if they've got
evidence of bad practice or where
they're concerned about their business
customers or what they can see in their
books which will provide to the
regulator but also provide to people
like Kate Nichols and UK Hospitality
um the non-domestic is a much more
complex pitch than domestic is the short
answer and the risk to the supplies is
much bigger because of the way that we
have to hedge for businesses and the
risk of businesses so to give you an
example a pub my local pub my local
hairdresser and my kids Nursery might
all have the same footprint might all
have similar energy demand but it'll be
at different times of day and they'll be
very different businesses in terms of
the risk-based suppliers so they all
require different contracts in different
terms the contract terms therefore can
look very different across the sector
like Kate's to a different sector of the
economy and that often leads to
businesses saying this feels unfair but
it's often just the reality of the risk
plus the cost of the energy at the
moment they're also not protected in the
same way as domestic customers and
things we've done apart from looking for
evidence of bad practice and again it's
the same messages on domestic as there
is by practice we're the first people to
want to call that Stamper out we're
working with business groups on the
support that they need and how quickly
we can bring it in and calling on
government to take care of businesses
and the way they have with retailers
we're concerned about the capacity in
government on non-domestic we think and
perhaps Jonathan will clarify but we
think there's only two people ish in off
gem working on non-domestic versus the
numbers working on domestic
um and then lastly there are we have
called for the regulation of third-party
intermediaries of which there are many
in the non-domestic space these are the
kind of energy Consultants Brokers Etc
um just to give you a flavor of 1000 ish
third party intermediaries in
non-domestic about three quarters of
small and micro businesses will get
their energy contracts through tpis
around them directly with supplies it's
about a third of the volume of contracts
and so we have said for a long time that
bit of the industry needs regulating
okay but
at the moment
how profitable is that bit of the
industry in comparison with domestic
Market it's hard to say because I'm
waiting on year-end figures which is not
what was it last year I don't know if
it's on my headband but I can provide to
do what I will say is they do make some
profit on that sector unlike in the
retail that would be that's where I'm
going this is my last Point chair
it strikes me that because of the very
intense stringent public-facing
regulation on the domestic Market a lot
of other things that are more profitable
are happening in the non-domestic market
and I just wonder whether my intuition
on that is correct and if so I know
you've said some things that you want
off German government to do but
critically do you think that those bills
are too high overall and that we need to
work to get them down or do you think
that it's
you know the market can make things a
bit easier and but but ultimately
they're not too high and you think the
industry is behaving appropriately I
think there's two answers that question
one is there a heterogeneous of the
market makes it difficult to say that
across the piece and we're you know
cooperating with the regulator and with
our own members to get kind of some
sense of what's going on the market as a
whole but I haven't seen any evidence of
that so far I and I it's that thing
about I appreciate the Instinct from
folks like UK Hospitality who say you
know my bills are higher than this other
bit of the economy or my bills are
higher than domestic households is this
how companies are surviving
I haven't seen any evidence of that and
we have asked that question of members
and it often is the case that the bills
are higher because the risk is greater
in that section of the economy UK
hospitality is struggling if you're
providing a five-year contract and
buying energy five years ahead and
hedging for that the reality is it's a
higher risk in that bit of the economy
to say one that's more stable and again
just you know pulling back from this
we've seen the figures from the IMF this
morning and we have seen the figures for
affordability and the cost of living
crisis across the piece and this looks
like a much bigger issue for both
businesses and for domestic householders
and something that is just about energy
pricing
thank you chair thank you you win a
prize for sticking to five minutes well
done um Ian Lavery please first time for
everything
the treatment of domestic customers Fire
Supplies is very few men
and I wouldn't have somebody briefly
could just explain the fact that there's
been more court orders of people dying
people cannot afford to eat in heaters
people are dying and as Julian mentioned
before millions of people include
vulnerable disabled people have been
disconnected you know that's the facts
of the matter and to be Humane can
somebody explain to me the the reports
and they can see a b report
foreign
how those record levels of called orders
being played by suppliers and the courts
are now agreeing
by the hundreds that they'll allow the
suppliers to basically end at people's
homes
exaggerated or other correct
so the reason that there are higher
levels of people going on to prepayment
meters is simply that there are higher
levels of debt
um and your point about the warrants
process that's one of the things that
we're talking to the consumer groups to
off Gem and Bay is about to see if we
can go further than the already
extensive process for putting people
onto a pre-payment meter that exists in
the supplier license including kind of
you know across industry principles
approach to to what those steps should
look like so we are not saying that
there there isn't rule breaking going on
or that there isn't some bad practice
but largely what this is is just people
cannot afford to pay their bills
the debt book is huge now facing
industry it's a 10-year high and so
you're seeing more of the debt
collecting practice
rooms
yes that's how the warrant process works
yeah
it's fortunes applying to the courts and
the courts are improving the the
suppliers can end up supplies
it's an absolute
[Music]
moving on from that it brings into
question the
um the the operations and the
performance of of our Dream during the
the energy crisis
um and and I wonder if the the panel
could see whether that absolutely happy
or not with the the performance of
evolved dream during the crisis how do
you rate the the performance could it be
better has it been okay
um so often has carried out a number of
what it calls market-wide compliance
reviews and I think as a regulator
they've got a much better Baseline of
where the industry is at in terms of the
sort of policies and processes they have
in place I also think as a regulator
they've got a much better understanding
of the financial resilience of suppliers
um to to where they were sort of in
previous years I think where we're
concerned is whether they've got a good
enough handle on tackling the process
failures that are happening at suppliers
which is which is what we've seen um and
the problem with impacting prepayment
meter customers so we're really looking
forward to this new review that they're
carrying out to look much deeper than
whether or not suppliers have the right
processes in place because it's how
they're being implemented by staff and
interpreted by staff on a day-to-day
basis because the cases we're seeing at
citizens advice show that there are gaps
in that area and you know we need we
need better Protections in place
um we'd also like off gem to think about
bringing in a new consumer Duty similar
to what exists in the financial services
sector to ensure that companies are
required to focus on the right outcomes
for their customers because I think that
will be increasingly important as we
move towards the new world where people
will be required to use energy in very
different ways as a result of the Net
Zero transition we just think we need to
um
uh sort of I guess refresh the consumer
protections to make sure that retailers
always have the right focus on on the
right outcomes for their customers
uh I would say that it's um they've had
a tough job uh nobody in this sector has
had an easy easy ride
um but the interests of
um profitability of suppliers have
become more uh mainstream Focus for
off-gem given the supply of failures
that has led to trade-offs and um we
would continue to urge them to balance
that with the interests of low-income
and vulnerable consumers that they hold
statutory duties for
um we disagreed with the ending of the
previous Safeguard tariff which was
providing deeper support for vulnerable
customers and we also chat continue to
challenge them on their approach around
standing charges and um which don't
currently take any account of income or
households usage or their payment type I
think if I may just add add one final
thing I think it's it's right that off
gem continues to work so closely with
the UK government in terms of its
response to this energy crisis there is
an affordability crisis government has
now got the uh the financial Firepower
to offer deepest support from April when
we see that huge Cliff Edge in April
with the ending of the energy bill
support scheme and the increase to 3 000
pounds of the energy price guarantee
that's going to result in households
experiencing all over the country 900
pounds increase in their energy bills
when they're already at record highs and
the government is the UK government
who's got the ability to offset that for
households due to the significant
savings that they're already making as a
result of their reduced cost of their
current program so I hope that there's a
balancing of the critique of energy
suppliers off Jen's role and the UK
governments okay thank you very much
um Alexander Stafford please well thank
you very much and thank you for your
answer just now please tell us basically
answering my question I'd like to ask
you anyway
you preemptive questions but basically
around this is not being a social tariff
coming in until April 2024 there is the
surprising bills uh should the
government do more how to Target I think
music clearly made it that the
government should do more and likely you
believe the government has the room to
do more is that the opinion shared by
the rest of the panel
and I guess how should that that extra
sport be targeted should be dark because
in the same way that the government's
doing at the moment should be different
how how would you see this extra support
coming in I think they're you know
others colleagues might come in on uh
the need for continuing some Universal
support and perhaps the business case
for keeping the EPG at the current
current level
um but we do need to in the short term
fill in the gaps uh in relation to those
cost living payments we know that
there's some big chasms for households
particularly those that we mentioned
earlier those are on low incomes but
aren't covered by means tested benefits
those households with medical conditions
that aren't going to be well targeted
through that cost of living payments and
they we need some focused attention to
plug those gaps from now until April but
when we get to April 2024
um and we cross over this really big
concern that we've got about this this
coming winter
um given the uh the cost of living Focus
uh payments we need to transition to
something which is much more sustainable
either a bigger much bigger rebate at
the start of winter or look to provide
households with an enduring mechanism
like a social tariff
so citizens advice have been carried a
really detailed piece of work with our
partners SMF Think Tank and public first
looking at the the future need for
social tariffs in the way in which
support could be delivered and we've
done a lot of opinion polling focus
groups with the public roundtables with
industry Civil Society politicians
trying to build a consensus on what that
social tariff should look like
um we're going to be publishing the
final report in the coming weeks and
we'll be happy to share a copy with the
committee now
um so the two leading options are a
fixed cash discount now that's something
that would look like the current warm
home discount but bigger and better
because the warm home discount isn't big
enough in terms of the discounted offers
and it doesn't reach enough people or
it's a percentage discount on the unit
rates both of those options pulled
really well with the public and they can
be designed in a way that ensures most
of the benefits accrue to low-income
households so it's really hitting those
people that we we want to hit with the
social tariff
the one Challenge and I do think this is
something we need to spend 2023 through
to April 24 on is fixing the problem of
people who aren't on means tested
benefits to ensure that it's about three
million households to ensure that we can
get that targeted support to them
automatically so we need a new we need a
new way of identifying those households
and that's probably going to involve
stuff like using hmrc data and that's
something the government should be
working on this year
um yes we're looking at I mean yes we're
looking at those options and the and the
members are talking to consumer groups
about them I think it's we need to look
at this in terms of
timelines so we're calling on government
to keep the energy price guarantee in
place so that it bills say around 2500
pound Mark and and this existing support
is maintained whilst we're working on
options we're looking at
um
the idea of a social tariff but we're
also happy to consider things like
expanded targeted support through things
like warm homes discount or a separate
thing we're also looking at expanded
support for Energy Efficiency there's an
overlap between fuel poverty
vulnerability and and some of the
households we've been talking about
um and then I think in the long run
we're also open to talking about Market
reform and we shouldn't forget there's
there's that at the heart of this this
is a retail market and just to correct
something that was said the retail
Market does not make money on average
it's a it's making negative margins it
is not a healthy Market to do this stuff
and then we need Market reform for
retail but you also need to be able to
capture some of the benefits coming
through of things like low-cost
Renewables and and some of these other
Technologies so I think we're also open
to like what does that market look like
and how can it benefit consumers in the
long run so three stages
a one minute left just briefly on the
market what would you the government
want to do next year or this year now
what would you want to do we're I mean
we're talking about exactly the things
that Jillian and Peter mentioned so it's
expanding the existing support schemes
and then looking at things we can bring
in quickly that are targeted like a
social tariff or expanding warframes
discount or similar
but we're very open to all options on
the table I think all bright ideas
welcome I know people just briefly
wanted to come in very briefly one of
the other priorities in the short term
is to levelize those payment methods as
I've already mentioned standard credit
customers paying a huge amount more than
compared to direct debit customer so
prepayment customers we need to look at
levelizing those costs um before it's
too late
um I want to stick with the social
tariff because clearly one of the
challenges we've got is identifying
those who are in need and require
support and both Emma and Peter did
speak about the use of smart meters in
this regard I'm just wondering if we can
tease that out a little bit more exactly
how I mean the government doesn't have a
brilliant record in the rollout of smart
meters and um it you know in the present
climate it seems to have been parked on
one side while we support people through
these difficulties but just tell us a
little bit more about how the use of
smart meters could help identify those
people who would benefit from the
application of a social tariff perhaps
Peter first yeah thank you and they're
they're already benefiting suppliers
suppliers that have customers that are
on prepayment and smart prepayment
meters are able to look at them when
they're regularly self-disconnecting
they're also able to actively monitor in
real time the amount of vans that those
households are putting on often where
there's Loose Change associated with a
particular event say it's four pounds 19
for example that indicates that the
household is maxed out and that they're
just trying to put as much on as
possible and by looking at those Trends
you can identify not just those
households that are already
self-disconnecting but proactively
obviously we're talking purely about
prepayment customers I I was wondering
about the broader realm of customers
maybe those who who pay by more
conventional means
I mean it's the same functionality that
Pete's describing that applied to
customers as a whole so I I don't know
if any of you participated in the great
big energy turned down over the last
week where we got householders to turn
down their supply but I have a smart
meter if you've got one and you're doing
that so you're turning off your lights
or you're shifting when you're cooking
you can see the kilowatts in your house
drop off now we you can see that as a
householder on your in-home display but
we can also see that as an industry and
we can use it so if we know what people
use on average we can help them do
things like load shifting so moving
around when they use energy which makes
the grid more efficient and saves money
as a whole so we think it's about 16
billion pound benefit back to the energy
system and being more flexible like this
um and then for things like
vulnerability that point I made at the
beginning the the household's now
falling into what we would deem
vulnerable or struggling to pay their
bills are not households that we have
traditionally classed as vulnerable so
it enables us to see people who would
never think of themselves in that way
who are shifting their behavior baby
with their energy or or at risk of
self-disconnection and all of those
things and getting early or add them to
you know priority customer service this
is essentially looking at patterns of
behavior yeah are there any unforeseen
consequences is there a danger that
somebody's a pattern of usage might
change for a perfectly valid reason and
it's not one that indicates uh you know
a financial difficulty whereas pizzas
you know people go to hospital or go on
holiday all those things so yeah yes but
we again you can easily fix that by
having that then communication with your
customer it's worth saying with things
like warrants enforced in stores or ppms
they had there it is required that
there's been a long process of
communication so you might see that
someone is changing their behavior on
their smart meter or they might contact
you with with a concern about paying
their bill and then it is required that
there is a very long process of talking
to that customer about what help they
could access what more could be done for
them where there are warrants issued or
you get to the kind of point of force
installation it's at a point where it's
it's people who won't pay or you haven't
been able to communicate with them at
all so one of the good things about
Smart Meters you can see the data to
start that conversation early you can
start offering interesting tariffs and
and services back to your customers we
can save money for the grid um because
it's critical infrastructure and we can
facilitate those conversations about
energy use and concerns about
vulnerability for some of the kinds of
households we've been talking about
who've never previously been vulnerable
and Peter you said that a social tariff
would need to sit alongside the energy
price cap if this uh if the social
tariff is dealing with those vulnerable
customers why can't we leave the market
to provide the right price level for the
remainder customers why do we need why
would we need both I don't know if it
would be retained in exactly the same
format but one of the main functions of
the wider price Gap at the moment is the
regulation of policy costs through to
bills there was a big uncertainty uh
previously about the extent to which
policy costs were driving up bills and
that led to Great distrust in some
instances around the the green economy
and the transition transparency by
Emma's members deal with that if people
knew exactly what they were paying on
these other on these other components of
the bill it potentially but I'd use all
your Armory to try and make sure that
there is transparency around that area
and it's a good news story uh for the of
the UK government at the moment on that
front legit so the price Camp was
originally put in place to address the
Loyalty penalty which was people who
didn't switch but it's not doing that is
it
um I think we're now in such a unique
situation where we don't have
competitive tariffs there is no
competition happening in the energy
Market at the moment it's that's because
the prices yeah I know it's been put on
life support there's no competition in a
market where somebody dictates the price
absolutely
um we used to have the coexistence of
the price cap and competition in the
market but following the start of the
energy price crisis and all the supplier
failures that has now disappeared and I
think there's a question about what the
new world will look like and this is I'm
sure something that does the new world
need a price Gap in addition to an
effective social attack I think it might
it might there's there's all there's
various options I think we definitely
need a social tariff in the new world
and it should be a social tariff that
doesn't take people out of the market so
ensures that they can still benefit from
all the Innovation that will be
happening because we very much want
low-income and vulnerable households to
be able to participate and benefit from
that Innovation if they're able to do so
thank you thank you Jeff thank you so
much Alan Brown please thanks here
um
Peter start with you if that's okay so
if we take figures from National energy
action it's predicted 8.4 million
households are in fuel poverty and come
April which is roughly third though oh
households so if we're looking at Energy
Efficiency installations
um is that a greater lead now to focus
on a wider range
of households to help in order to reduce
demand energy demand overall which
long-term also helps mobile pairs or
there's still a need to focus in those
in the greatest Financial need and on
our latter point is there any concern
about
um Eco plus only having a 20 focus in
early income households
yeah thank you thank you for that
question so I think um it's it's true
that uh any household that's living in
an energy inefficient home will fill the
price point much more keenly so a
typical 3 000 pound Energy bill in April
will film much more like four thousand
five hundred five thousand pounds for
those households living in the least
efficient homes
um but we do need to continue to make
progress on our statutory for your
poverty commitments that it's written
into law that we should tackle this
vicious overlap between the households
that live on the lowest incomes and also
inhabit the least efficient homes
there's about three million in England
alone that live in properties below band
c
um in a very helpful way I think Chris
Skidmore the other day and his report
set out the not just the moral case but
the economic case for doing that
um so if we help those households
through Energy Efficiency measures it
doesn't only help the environment but it
also returns money much more quickly
back to local economies and has a a
better sort of multiplier effect if you
focus on low income and vulnerable homes
as well as the huge health health
benefits so I think they're good reasons
to continue with the focus particularly
where those policies that are funding
Energy Efficiency improvements are Levy
funded it would be particularly grueling
to see a disproportionate focus on
affluent households who theoretically
could pay for some of that investment in
Energy Efficiency themselves if it's
being subsidized by poorer households
that need those measures the most
and sometimes talk about in a sleeper
Street Arab area approach is enough done
on that
um because it seems to me it's actually
then contracts proficiencies if you set
up an area contractor sets up a compound
you bring in the materials welfare
facilities you've got a base rather than
you know kind of more ad hoc approach as
so as and I've done in targeting key
areas in
my results go for much greater
efficiency and then greater installs I
think we could do a whole evidence
session on Energy Efficiency rollouts
um which is I suppose they go we'd be
found so we used to work together on
Energy Efficiency a long time ago
they're
um and the reason the reason we think is
valuable is it's about I think it's
three or four pounds back to the
exchecker for every pound spent on
Energy Efficiency because of saving
money on bills and and in The Wider
economy
the thing that's worked with Energy
Efficiency role actually has been that
the suppliers have done it so you kind
of get that scale that you're talking
about and we have targeted vulnerable
households and and the most in need
there is a very live debate going on
um LED actually by the industry about
expanding Eco to help more households
we've put in a request for that support
into the chancellor for the spring
statement
then then there's a longer term
conversation about how you get the kind
of economy-wide Energy Efficiency
against you're talking about and whether
it's Street by Street or another
approach I think we'd be all up for that
longer term conversation for now as with
all of this I think what we're saying is
you've got to bank what works in a
crisis and do as much of it as possible
so we're talking about expanding the
existing Eco scheme rather than kind of
tearing up paperwork and doing something
new that doesn't mean that there isn't
room for how do you help be able to pay
Market do this how do you get it going
through communities what's the role of
local authorities but that Darren could
be the subject of a whole other inquiry
I think
right and another is enough been done in
terms of the private renting sector
because basically the UK government is
supposed to come back and implement the
targets and and for that but that's
still outstanding so appear it's a it's
a massive concern I think it's been over
five years since the government
initially moved it in a clean growth
strategy for the two years since they
had a very detailed consultation in
terms of improving and extending those
requirements in the private rented
sector
um huge amount of uncertainty for
tenants
um as a result and a huge amount of
needless energy expenditure during what
has been a cost of living crisis so
there's huge consequences to the delay
of setting out what those targets should
be there's also now a link between those
private rented sector standards and the
standards that we should expect to
social landlords and that that Hiatus is
inexcusable particularly in the context
of trying to meet our field poverty
commitments given how many households
are in the private rented sector and
also live in fuel poverty
low income households
um customers are expected to pay 10
towards install course
is it worth keeping that ten percent
billing and place or our two main
households going to miss out Governor
said that third of the households and
fuel poverty
I think the capital sort of hard wiring
Capital contributions into the scheme
precludes almost deliberately the
contribution of the poorest household so
uh it's a really poor policy decision in
our view I think the only area that
could be justified is if the Eco plus
scheme is going to be across 10 years
requiring an even higher Capital
contribution from the landlord is
absolutely the right thing to do that
can make the jam go a little bit further
who a thank you I'm so sorry to keep
everybody moving on a very important
subject but we have another two panel so
thank you to all three of you uh for
your contributions this morning we're
now moving on to our second panel where
we'll be talking about non-domestic
customers so businesses public services
and others and we're welcoming Tina
McKenzie the national Vice chair and
chair of policy and advocacy for the
Federation of small businesses Stephen
phippsen who's the chief executive for
Meek UK and Kate Nichols the chief
executive of UK hospitality
okay
thank you
that's my bill
that's my ability
and they're offering me
for me sandwiches thank you and good
morning to uh all of you
um so just to kick us off it would be
useful to get your individual uh
perspectives
specifically the implications of high
energy bills for businesses and what
you're seeing in terms of
companies going bus as a consequence of
having to make different decisions and
if at all possible trying to distinguish
that from other economic factors if that
is at all possible just so we can try to
really focus in on the on the energy
aspects um at Kate Nichols first please
well thank you very much chair and thank
you for inviting me here today to to
give evidence to you I think it is
incredibly difficult to separate out
those energy challenges from The Wider
economic challenges that we've got
across the hospitality sector but I will
do my very best to do so because I think
there is some emerging evidence of what
you've what you're seeing obviously
we're facing into quite a perfect storm
you've got long economic covid affecting
the sector with high debt levels you've
had no real time for Recovery to be
building back cash reserves and you've
got half of our members saying they have
no cash reserves and a third of them
that are still not trading profitably
over the course of this year so it is
quite difficult to to dissociate what we
have seen however is a marked change in
the role energy plays in the business
model for hospitality and the increasing
significance in in terms of business
viability going forward so pre-pandemic
if you looked across the hospitality
sector at an individual Outlet level
energy costs were typically around four
to six percent of turnover higher in
some of those high energy usages
particularly around hotels they've now
become 15 to 17 percent of turnover at
an outlet level it's gone from being the
fourth largest cost center to the second
more than rent and rates combined and
the only bigger cost that you've got
before you open your doors is your
Staffing and that's why it's become such
a big significant factor in in business
viability decisions in seeing whether
you are going concern because before you
meet any of your other costs you've got
to meet those high energy bills and be
able to cover them and know that when
you open on a Monday a wet Monday in
January in the Northeast where I come
from you've got to be able to cover it
roughly about eight to nine hundred
pounds before you turn a penny profit to
make the decision as to whether it's
worth opening what we have therefore
seen is quite a different Trend over the
course of the last year in business
failures in the sector we had a
contraction of about six percent across
the sector as a whole 5 000 businesses
closed for Good over the course of 2022
and about 3 three quarters of them were
in the last quarter of the year that's
highly unusual we normally have our
business failures coming at the start of
the year not in the third and fourth
quarter people usually hang on to trade
their way through Christmas and get some
cash in the tank we're not seeing that
and as I say three quarters of today's
business failures were happening
um September October November December
and the one of the largest factors that
was talked about in those business
failures particularly amongst the
Independence was energy costs they just
weren't able to manage to to to cover
those costs and remain sustainable and
viable so the inflationary environment
the cost of doing business yes that is
all a factor
um the discretionary spend downturn the
rail and travel disruption we are facing
into that perfect storm but energy is a
more significant factor in business
failure in our sector than it has ever
been in the 30 years I've worked in the
industry thank you Stephen fibson
um same issues really chat I think in
terms of uh disaggregating the
challenges that manufacturers have got
in terms of labor costs and supply chain
disruption everything else however we
are have done a lot of work with
manufacturers around the energy cost
itself which has gone up in our surveys
as a as a top priority for many
manufacturers in terms of risking their
businesses going forwards I'd like to
use the example of a machine shop
producing parts for the Aerospace
industry pre just before we introduced
the lbs their annual cost of electricity
was around 160 000 pounds a year and it
was rising to 1.1 million pounds a year
the challenge for those kinds of SME
manufacturers is they're often locked
into two-year or three-year pricing
arrangements with prime contractors no
chance of passing that on whatsoever so
the fact we got in the ebrs at that
stage was very welcome to those kinds of
companies but it shows you really the
long-term nature of these of the pricing
arrangements and the inability of those
companies to increase prices we see that
replicated across the sector
I think the other thing I would point
out and you're probably going to ask
this uh later on in the session chair is
um the the behavior of energy suppliers
in the industrial sector for these sorts
of smaller companies has been has been
very variable and very difficult we're
now seeing in in a phase where companies
are being asked for hundred thousand
pound security deposits up front to
switch contracts and the wholesale price
that we talk about the the the schemes
that the government has often not
filtering through in terms of those
discounts to those suppliers so we
welcome the Chancellor's comments about
regulate bringing off gem in to regulate
the industrial sector that's important
but on top of everything else that's
something these companies do not do not
need so it's been quite tough in terms
of specifics right now we estimate from
our survey data that around 13 of
manufacturers in this country are
operating on break even and without cash
reserves with the current level of
energy support and you in with
withdrawing that or that becomes worse
that's going to tip them over the edge
so that's the group that's most at risk
in our sector out of a community of
around 250 000 manufacturers in the
country thank you Tina McKenzie I mean
where does the business get the cash
flow from if if they've already taken on
debt in the pandemic they've got no cash
reserves these costs are coming through
the doors I mean where do they go well
they've limited choices to where they go
and but I think it's important to say
that the IMF figure is Right today and
they show that the UK has got a
contraction we were supposed we were
looking at hopefully a small increase
but across G7 we're the only country
with a 0.6 contraction everyone else is
due to grow and interestingly that 99 of
the businesses in the UK are smes we
know that five it was selling a 5.9
million in 2020 going into covid we know
for a fact it then dropped over those 12
months to five and a half million so
we've already lost hundreds of thousands
of smes in the country and we're not yet
we haven't yet been given the absolute
figures of the last 12 months and but we
do think the introduction of the ebrs
certainly saved a lot of businesses up
and down the country in terms of where
they go they've got few choices we've
seen from the ons stats that actually
case reserves are down to some of the
lowest levels because of all the other
things those businesses are facing but
actually they can increase prices and
our survey shows that a percentage of
businesses are looking to do that they
can push all of that into a price
increase so others are looking to close
dying or to change their businesses or
indeed to go offshore
thank you very much Alan Brown please
thank you
um just type yourself Tina so the
chancellors brought an energy bill
discount scheme um from April and you
said outstaught businesses facing the
cliff Edge that provides a transition
but the rally address is 0.7 P discount
per unit of gas 0.2 P unit of
electricity discount and FSB described
um these levels of sport this total and
significant for small businesses so what
does that support work like for a
typical small business and what what's
effect has it does it remove the clef
heads or or not let's say approved for
small businesses
no it's absolutely pitiful and we were
clear about that in our messaging and
clear about that to government as well
um unfortunately a lot of businesses
tied into fixed prices
um over the period of let's say August
September last year and so they were
tying into prices usually around 75 80
Pence which if you had the fixed support
from the government then it wasn't an
issue because the the
um the price per kilowatt was capped
neither that's taken away and we have a
few pennies over 30p that will be
discounted if you're sitting in a
contract you can't get out of for the
next two years at 75 80 Pence then quite
quickly that couple of pennies over 30p
on the discount isn't really going to do
much at all to help you and that's the
point where a lot of businesses actually
still haven't even realized what's about
to hit them with those bills that are
coming in April May June and we're quite
worried about that Cliff Edge when those
bills hit what's going gonna happen now
we do know that wholesale prices have
gone down and that's something that
people have said well is there anything
to worry about if the wholesale prices
have gone down but yes on the one hand
we have these people fixed into these
really high contracted prices
um but on the other hand looking around
the world at the moment with the
geopolitical situation we've got we feel
like
um we may be gambling a little bit early
on stability and low wholesale prices
and that's what we're quite concerned
about any other
um Global move in and there's several
things going on around the world could
absolutely affect that wholesale price
and businesses are in real trouble again
okay so what reforms offended to learn
their Bill's Discount scheme would you
like to see
Kevin what you've said that is pitiful
at the moment so what what reforms would
you like to see we would have liked to
have seen the government
um ring fence and help the most
vulnerable businesses and that is the
smallest micro businesses which in a
sense are like domestic users and
domestic users are still protected
domestic consumers so some of those
micro businesses and that are so
vulnerable and have no cash reserves we
would have liked them to have given them
a bit more of a landing so a bit more
time we as a country have spent billions
supporting businesses to stay open
through covid and it would be just you
know it doesn't make signed economic
sense to let them go and disappear now
and
with Energy prices and with them being
tied into such high price contracts so
it for us it's not good economics it
doesn't make sense if we to ring fence
some of the smallest most vulnerable
businesses and they are by the way in
the country some of the businesses that
are actually high energy users like your
pubs sunbed Shops and and butcher shops
and the list goes on some of our
smallest businesses that are so
important to the local communities use a
lot of energy
dear members Echo the thoughts that
teenagers shared there absolutely I
think you had for more members of around
three quarters of them were renewing
energy contracts ahead of October so
they were locking in to try and get a
contract they were having to pay very
high security put deposits as Stephen
has said in order to just secure a
contract not even to look at changing
but just to secure a contract
um and until you've got lots of
businesses that are locked in at very
high rates that were locked in over the
summer who when they come out of
contract or when we move away from the
support
um they're not going to see it drop as
significantly in terms of price and then
on top of that over over and above the
sort of level of commodity price which
is regulated you've got non-commodity
charges which are making up an
increasing part of the bill and meaning
that our customers are still facing a
significant High retail charge for them
so we're estimating that veraca for our
members across the board the average
price increase is going to be around 85
percent when we come out of support in
April because of the level of the cap
that Tina's talked about in a very low
level of support and then you've still
got members who are still facing 150 200
percent increases in price as we go
through that so we're not seeing the
suppliers passing on the drop in
wholesale price and we're also seeing
large numbers of members who are
contracted in and are not coming up for
renewal for quite a period of time okay
so after spending 18 billion energy
about the relief scheme
um
it's it's basically the government just
paying that money to Steve but just
delaying their neighbor to collapse to
some businesses unless it's a massive
reform well the the scheme that was put
in place undoubtedly saved many
thousands of jobs and businesses in our
sector that would have other guys gone
to the wall because of the situation we
were facing with energy and it's energy
that is The Game Changer in in our
sector we're a viable vibrant sector of
the economy we're the third largest
employer we've generated revenue of
around 130 billion and 40 billion pound
tax take for the exchequer so we're a
hugely important part of the economy and
when we fire on all census the economy
starts to grow and we recover so it's
undoubtedly the case that that scheme
was vital to get businesses through I
think the cliff Edge has been
shaved off slightly and the sort of drop
has been filled in but for many
businesses they will still see a
significant increase in costs because of
the introduction of a cap and the very
low level of support that we're seeing
from April so we would have preferred to
see the approach that was previously
been talked about where vulnerable
sectors and Hospitality was name checked
by the the chancellor the business
secretary and the Prime Minister
previously as being vulnerable and
needing more support we would have liked
to see additional support to hospitality
from April
thank you very much Mark Posey please
thank you chair I want to focus on the
treatment of businesses by energy
suppliers and start off with Kate if I
may and you were very critical and
points out there are some Road companies
and I think that was acknowledged by
Emma pinchback in her early evidence
session that there are one or two
companies who haven't behaved as they
might have done but can you just give us
a sense of how extensive this problem is
and the experiences of any of your
members the situation that we've got
with hospitality is very few energy
suppliers will contract with hospitality
they treat the sector as a whole as
being at risk rather than looking at
individual companies so there is a sort
of blank at risk premium so we do find
therefore that any problems that emerge
are magnified because you've got a
smaller number of employee a smaller
number of suppliers typically three or
four a Hospitality unit
sees that contract coming to an end they
pick up the phone and can't do it bring
apart from suppliers and you're saying
that how many out of half a dozen would
say sorry we're not willing to supply
your sector
you've got three or four main main uh
suppliers that Supply the sector you've
got a general unwillingness to let
people move contracts you've got higher
charges that are being applied for
security deposits and risk premiums that
are applied if you want to try and
switch so switching is very difficult so
competition doesn't exist what we then
noticed over the course of the last year
in the first half of the year we saw
very high security deposits being being
attached to get a supply and contract
terms being applied but then once the
government regulated the wholesale price
and the commodity price we then saw
significant changes in practice where
there was an acceleration of increases
in service charges access charges and
non-commodity charges so you're seeing
five to six hundred percent increases
put through on standing charges that
meant that the bill was significantly
higher so those are the kind of
practices we've seen we've also seen
quite a few companies not be able to
pass on that discount that the
government scheme is providing including
some very big providers in the the
sector saying they can't apply the
discount to bills until January because
their systems don't allow them to do it
these are vulnerable businesses that
need support straight away and some of
the biggest energy suppliers are not
passing it through those examples that
you've given so they common or are there
some good guys amongst all of this there
are some very good guys amongst all of
this there are those that have seen uh
you know recognized that security
deposits don't need to be six months of
energy Supply which inevitably is a
higher charge there are many that have
kept what is your organization doing to
pass on details to your members of the
companies that are reputable and worth
dealing with in this sector and those
that perhaps they should avoid we we
have regular seminars with our members
and webinars we've had Liaisons with
energy UK and off gem to be able to
identify what is a good and bad practice
and to provide that information and
advice and guidance to our members to
direct them in their negotiations and
contract discussions but inevitably
although we represent large companies as
well there is an imbalance of power if
you are a single site independent Pub
bar restaurant Hotel talking to an
energy supplier sometimes even with the
best of Endeavors from UK Hospitality we
can't get traction on that and Stephen
you first drew our attention to these
security deposits but let me put it to
you if one of your manufacturing members
were supplying a sector that was
emerging and pretty risky they might
want some form of deposit from their
customer before proceeding with a
bespoke manufactured product so what's
unreasonable about an energy company
saying you know some of these businesses
are liable to fail if they fail we will
end up with a bad debt so we can insure
ourselves against that by our by asking
for a deposit why shouldn't they do that
and your rights draw the attention to
the insurance element which comes out
very strongly when we're talking about
why they are actually requesting these
security deposits in the first place I
think it's a change in Behavior I think
one of the things we're doing as an
organization is trying to help companies
particularly smaller companies who don't
normally have to do a financial
presentation to their Energy company
about the financial robustness of their
organization to try to encourage them to
give them an energy contract that sort
of process is new so right or wrongs
aside for us it accounts the Energy
company can look at usually a year
so so is it unreasonable for an energy
to come to say look if you provide me
with evidence that your business is
secure I'm happy to uh forego the
security deposit that I might need from
another company it is probably entirely
reasonable however what we're finding is
the majority of energy companies are
then not proceeding to offer a contract
it's too risky it's too difficult we
need a bigger deposit if we're going to
do that which leaves a lot of these
companies struggling for where they're
going to get those energy contracts in
the future that's becoming a real
problem okay so what's the solution the
solution is regulation the solution is
off gem should be and I think the
chancellor is doing this to be to be
fair and he's called for this
consultation and or not so much a
consultation but I think an inquiry of
off gem as to how they might intervene
in the industrial engine Market to make
sure that there is a Level Playing Field
here so we all understand what the rules
are going forward I think that would
help enormously
and Tina um I think ffp said that 2023
is looking like the beginning of the end
for thousands of small businesses isn't
that a bit dramatic
when you looked at what happened
thousands of businesses absolutely these
These are these are Innovative
entrepreneurs and you're telling me
they're not able to adapt
okay would you like me to give you some
examples of what some of these
businesses are facing I've got a a whole
pack of examples where businesses are
going up from where they may be standing
at an annual charge on their energy of
around two to three thousand going up to
60 70 80 000 and when you imagine a lot
of these are smes with who were running
on maybe profits of twenty Thirty forty
thousand you can automatically see they
become unviable I think you know we've
written to the energy suppliers and I
agree with what the others have said
about the the standing charges and you
know if we were in a normal Market
scenario then you know what the market
plays out and small businesses and the
FSB are varying to normal market
conditions in the market playing right
but we're not in that environment and
when we get into a tricky situation
where the prices went astronomical and
they were completely abnormal because of
the war then that's what we let me just
finish quickly that's where we saw these
deposits and caps increase significantly
and that's what we feel like some
suppliers to took advantage of a
situation the country was facing and
that was unfair okay so what do we need
for a normal Market scenario well I
think we need to go back to what the
barriers to entry are for organizations
becoming energy suppliers in this
country we did that and we had loads of
people we had one giving evidence to us
here we've started a business out of his
front room and went Buster and those had
to be the government had to step in to
support those the people who were
customers of that business so we've got
to be a bit careful haven't we you know
so first the first thing is you don't
want to stay of entrepreneurs we are a
country of entrepreneurs we want to give
people an open opportunity but at the
same time when you're speaking of
something so important is energy and
there are many other Industries like it
where it is the heartbeat not just for
consumers but of our businesses across
the UK then we need to ensure that those
businesses going in there have their own
healthy cash reserves but also are
living by rules that if the country gets
into a situation where our um energy is
really significantly reduced and under
such risk that they do not continue take
advantage as you would maybe in a normal
Market scenario that is not too much to
ask for and that's in fact why we have a
government in order to ensure that when
we get into these situations that we
protect the most vulnerable and we don't
drive our economy off a cliff that's
really important are you agreeing with
Stephen that there's a role here for Off
Gym absolutely and we've been speaking
to talk to him about it and we would
like to say off gem with the
consultation after him have more teeth
with this and have more time and energy
to spend on it more resources and I
think that would absolutely help the
sector for the future if we get into one
of these scenarios again also another
thing that's going to help here is if we
encourage and we are encouraging the
government with help to Green schemes so
that businesses and consumers are not so
reliant on on the increases and
decreases the volatility of the normal
markets that we can put people on to
some of the green schemes and actually
they can be self-sufficient in their
energy and we're not dictated to by
actions such as Russia in the future hey
thank you thank you very much Ruth
Edwards please
thank you chair I should probably just
declare that I um have had the pleasure
of working with Stephen in one of his
formal roles and I also know Kate
outside of the committee
um just to carry on on the theme of
off-gen
um how you've talked about what you'd
like off gems to do in the future how
would you rate off gems performance in
protecting non-domestic customers your
members up throughout sort of energy
crisis to date okay do you want to start
yes thank you I mean we have worked with
off gem over the course of the crisis we
first flagged that this was an issue we
are tend to be the canary in the coal
mine because of the experiences of our
members that we have but we first
flagged this as an issue with government
and with off German February last year
so this has been an escalating crisis
and I think the only criticism I would
make is pace and scale and sense of
urgency and I think Echo some points
that were made on the previous panel
that the focus has undoubtedly been on
domestic customers and that this sector
has sort of been a bit of a Cinderella
and not had the same attention and scope
so we have been flagging these issues
with Off Gym off gem has used their
convening power to gather good suppliers
together to try and address common
concerns but it has been quite difficult
to get acceptance and traction that
there are issues here that need to be
looked at as we've gone through the
crisis so so I think you know when the
government started to hold off gems feet
to the fire and off geminine held
suppliers feature the fire in November
that was when we started to see a marked
a material difference and a willingness
to engage in in constructive dialogue
about how we could solve these problems
together I think prior to that there was
an element of denial going on amongst
energy suppliers that there was a real
issue that businesses were facing and
what progress have you seen since since
November we've seen quite rapid progress
there's been several meetings there's
been evidence Gathering both from the
businesses that are affected who are are
frustrated at some of the terms that are
being opposed because it is right and
proper that we make sure we've got a
valid evidence base and Gathering
evidence from the suppliers to look at
where the real issues of priority are
and then after Germans being able to
drill down on those issues to
particularly around deemed pricing where
people are on variable daily rates which
were exceptionally High non-commodity
charges and security deposits that are
escalating the price and inflating the
price that people are paying for energy
bills so we've been quite heartened by
the progress since November and we've
had several positive meetings with
ministers and with off gem over the last
couple of weeks thank you Stephen what's
your experience been
um I think uh to be fair to off-term
they haven't really had the remit to
look at the industrial energy sector
that's not been their area of focus in
terms of Regulation so so um the
resources devoted inside of off-term to
this have been very very small so good
conversations but not much resource
hence welcoming the chancellors
intervention recently they have of
course on the non-commodity charges been
the regular that is fairly regulated
across the piece so that element the
eight to twelve percent of your energy
bill that's the non-commodity prices is
regulated by off John off gem but the
rest of it isn't and what we're asking
for here is to broaden their remits to
give them that responsibility to bring
that in and I think that's exactly where
the chances are the question but that's
going to mean more resources for off
Gemma I think do this job properly yeah
I think that's a fair comment and now
we've obviously heard from energy UK in
the previous panel their view is that
off-gen doesn't have the resources or
the sort of expertise
um to enforce
um existing their existing regulatory
role properly is that something you
would agree with or well certainly I'm
not so sure on the consumer side because
that's not my area of expertise but
certainly on the industrial energy side
they're going to need to stand up a
proper team to do this properly and then
we need to do that properly quite
quickly
thank you Tina what's the office please
View
yeah I think it comes back to it's
twofold it isn't just about off gem it's
also about
um the energy companies themselves in
terms of who we allow you to enter on
what basis what reserves they have what
rules they're under but also in off gem
in terms of looking to police that and
have some par with that certainly more
resources is needed more expertise more
finance and a bigger scope and it's
going to take some time I think to get
that right the good news is we are now
in a period where the prices are lower
we have a maybe a window of opportunity
I hope that the prices we don't have
another shock in the market and the
prices don't go up quite significantly
over a short period of time but once we
have these dropping prices this is the
perfect time to get into off gym and and
get it right thank you and just one
quick follow-up on your comments earlier
you mentioned that the government should
be looking to ring fence
um the smallest and help the smallest
businesses
um how would you advise that we could
best identify
those businesses who needed the most
help we've given a few uh examples of
how they can do that something simple is
those businesses that use less than a
certain amount of hours in energy per
year and that you can identify quite
quickly they're the micro businesses
there's lots of different ways to
identify it and actually we feel like it
wouldn't cost the the government a lot
of money what it will do is stop energy
firms taking advantage of those smallest
businesses who really don't know when
they're coded a contract of 75 85p a
pound per hour they really don't know
sometimes what they're signing up to
and what what's your view on what the
cost would be to the FSB have any idea
of the skill and we've done some course
things which we can forward to the
committee we've done some Crossings on
various different scenarios depending on
how you define it
let's see one more final question um to
you it's obviously no um
not a substitute for reform of the
energy Market but we have seen in
Germany a number of manufacturing
businesses save a huge amount of money
on energy costs by just by rethinking
their their processes have we see are
any of your members doing that are you
what sort of conversations are going on
with firms who are making breakthroughs
here to spread that best practice so
manufacturing sector in this country is
an extremely Innovative sector so on our
current surveys 39 of manufacturers in
the country are investigating or
starting to invest in alternative
sources of energy and certainly on the
efficiency side of their processes
that's important
um brings up another point about support
an encouragement from government I mean
the long term isn't subsidy for energy
costs for industrial the long term is
reform of the energy market and its
investment in more efficient processes
so um I think the latest the energy
transformation fund for example comes to
an end in two weeks time
we haven't got anything to replace those
funds those incentives after this and
one of the calls we've had with treasury
is what are we going to do now because
we should be encouraging these
businesses to look at a lot more of
these alternative Investments to get
them off the dependency of high energy
costs that's really really important so
we'd welcome that some of that can be
done on their own but for the smaller
businesses for the smes in the
manufacturing sector they're going to
need some help and that that help comes
in the form of either funds like the
energy transformation fund which was
rather complex to access but that's a
whole other subject or it comes in terms
of tax incentives and investment in
those green technologies so that's a
real push for us at the moment with
Treasury
thank you very much uh thanks Jeff just
keeping on the theme of energy intensive
Industries I mean there's much uh
alternative available to them today so I
I just want you to inform us about their
competitiveness I'm thinking of Steel
Ceramics uh chemical and process
Industries
um if if they go uh we might be in
trouble and the smes that flow they're
from will also be in trouble so is it
are you seeing that impact in terms of
competitors we are indeed so so the
situation on energy intensives there's
two points really on the ebds scheme the
new scheme that's coming out post April
the definition of trade intensity and
energy intensity uh is done by sick code
basically if you look at the way that
they've arranged this which means it
goes in your primary sit code so there's
a lot of companies that are energy
intensive companies car companies that
make batteries and produce have
foundries on site which are not now
going to be included in the new scheme
because their primary sick code doesn't
allow them to be in that category and
that applies throughout tree so we've
seen we see a calculation of a reduction
of about 10 percent of businesses that
we would have considered energy
intensives to be able to qualify for
ebds that's one of the challenges of
that scheme on your point about
competitiveness
um we it Remains the case if we look at
what's happening in places like Spain
and Portugal where they have now
decoupled gas prices from electricity
prices they've taken out Network charges
from industrial bills it means that the
difference in the new scheme going
forwards is about 60 percent difference
in terms of our prices being more
expensive for those energy and even with
a generous 30 discount on everything
else we remain highly uncompetitive
compared to a lot of the European
countries that means switching
production that misses for things like
steel we're talking about global
commodity prices here very often some of
those those plants have got sister
plants in European or other countries
and what we have seen is them taking
decisions about whether to operate that
day or not depending on the spot price
of electricity that will continue and as
the disparity between us and Europe
grows going forwards that will become
more of a risk to Our Own Foundation
Industries which are absolutely critical
to industrialization and so given that
we're the highest throughout the 24
countries in terms of our Energy prices
are you seeing that real realization of
people saying with daily decisions being
taken in those plants about whether to
operate or not depending on today's spot
price compared to their sister
organization where they could transfer
production yeah so I'm going to wrap up
them with this chair but is that the
case that we see Liberty Steel I mean
they've cited high energy costs
leading to 440 redundancies there are
you seeing signs that that's going to
happen and if so which which are the
sectors that are most concerning to you
steel is the number one for me I mean if
you look at that that's um absolutely I
mean they're all vital chemical we're
seeing the same things in chemical
Industries at the moment as well but as
you can imagine in fact some of the
chemical plants aren't now included in
the EBD because of this sick code issue
but that's a that's a technicality but
it's the comparison between what's going
on in Europe if you look at the way that
they're handling their energy crisis
compared to the prices surely the
chemical and process Industries are the
ones that are most agile they've got the
ability to go to Holland and Germany
that's very very quick exactly and they
will do that's the problem rather than
keeping it here yeah okay thank you
chair okay thank you just one very quick
follow-up so I I heard the evidence
around businesses changing their
processes or their energy use to reduce
their energy consumption needs for
businesses though that are in offices or
pubs or hotels are we seeing landlords
come forward with investment to improve
Energy Efficiency and those settings or
not
we are to an extent it depends on the
type of landlord in our sector if you've
got commercial landlords and you're on
the High Street they are not coming
forward in the same way you are seeing
that from some of the pub industry Pub
company owning landlords where they're
doing refurbishments and doing
co-investment in kitchen technology in
particular it's undoubtedly the case
though that where you're looking at that
investment in in Green Technology or
you're doing a refurbishment of a site
which would typically take place every
seven years the energy efficient uh
induction Hobs lighting Etc are more
expensive than the the non-green
alternative and so Stephen's absolutely
right looking at some of those tax
incentives looking again at the
definition of an r d tax credit looking
at the capital allowances for our sector
Capital allowances
um you have to make a profit to benefit
from a capital allowance so you can have
a capital allowance and it's not getting
you anywhere so bringing forward some
more Innovative schemes to allow people
to make the the investment in in more
expensive technology and kit when
they're doing a kitchen refurb will be
be undoubtedly beneficial but we are
going to need to change the definition
of the r d tax credit and look again at
how it's done and this did more report
identifies some of the Moon shot
approaches that have been taken where
that is offset against pre-profit taxes
rather than post-profit taxes which is
our scope anything final tight on that
team just to say that a lot of our
members are small commercial landlords
and due to the uncertainty in the market
they're not investing in the premises
and we're not seeing that in terms of
energy and that is for a number of
reasons it's the uncertainty in the
market the lack of availability of kite
the fact that a lot of people have
actually got more loans and carrying
more debt uh than ever before and also a
lack of availability of information
about what's available out there certain
parts of the country have got good
suppliers
um in terms of going in and delivering
some green efficient Energy Solutions
other parts of the country don't I'm
particularly thinking of some of those
rural times that are really being
impacted we've also got a lot of High
Street to come down your high streets if
you're in a small town and you'll see a
lot of commercial premises are simply
not just empty and so therefore we're
not seeing a huge investment from those
landlords we think something has to be
done to Kickstart it sure can I just
start add one of our members survey did
show as well that a large proportion of
our members who were wanting to make
energy Investments um in energy
efficiencies at 80 of them looking to do
so their working capital was
predominantly tied up in energy security
deposits sitting with their energy
suppliers so their ability to do that
there's millions of pounds that is just
dead Capital sitting in security
deposits an interesting thought to
finish at that panel thank you to all
three of you for your contributions as
ever but very grateful we're now going
to move on to the final panel uh and
we're gonna be welcoming to the top
table uh Jonathan Braley the chief
executive of off gem who I think might
have just run to the Louvre so hopefully
by the time and Neil Kenwood director of
strategy and interim director of markets
off Gem and Neil Lawrence the director
of retail for office gem so we'll just
change over the names and cups
okay just as we're waiting for Jonathan
um to get back into the room if I could
just pick up some of the issues that
came up in our previous panel
um uh oh Jonathan hi
so I was just going to erase some of the
issues that came up in the previous
um uh panels
um particularly
um some of the comments from energy UK
which I thought were interesting I mean
the trade body for the energy companies
is basically saying some of them aren't
following the rules and you should tell
them off more but shouldn't they just be
following the rules in the first place
so chair as you know we were wanting to
give a kind of broader overview of the
market but just to focus on that for a
moment I am deeply concerned by the
comments that came from energy UK today
so there is a good debate about whether
we should enforce more and how we run
our compliance processes and we will
have those today but the idea that the
industry say the way we obey the rules
is by making the regulator enforce more
shows to me a deep problem with the
culture and the approach that some in
the industry are taking now quite
frankly I don't think that represents
the conversations I've had with CEOs and
I don't think that represents the
attitude of the industry as a whole but
step one for a CEO of any company is to
make sure they are looking after their
customers yes we can enforce yes we can
make sure we run compliance processes
but that is their day job why do you
think that was the answer we were given
earlier are there companies that just
are choosing not to follow the rules
because they're going to go bust
otherwise or they don't care or I don't
understand the rationale for the
evidence we had I think
I think the industry has been under
enormous pressure we have to accept that
I think there is still more to do to get
pricing regulation right to make sure
the finances work properly in the sector
we accept that but I don't think that
represents a sector that I see today I
think there are problems and we will
root them out and indeed we have done so
but you have to start as a company with
doing what's right for a customer so I
simply don't accept that the evidence
that was given okay
um Jonathan if you wouldn't mind would
you just mind giving the committee an
update on the status of the supplier
Market as you usually do thank you yes
of course well look just to start
um we recognized I'm sure everyone in
this committee recognizes that customers
are in an incredibly difficult position
right now so the gas crisis has had
stages and right now we are seeing the
full impact on customers bills now I
talk to customers almost every week and
I have talked to customers who've been
put onto prepayment meters I've talked
to families who are in distress and I've
talked to businesses who face some of
the big uplifts and charges that you've
seen today and before I get on to some
of the questions questions around that
and what it means for us I thought I'd
just talk about more broadly what's
happening in the market itself
so you'll remember last time we were
here and over summer we thought that
without the price guarantee the price
might be almost six thousand pounds a
year for the average household
now there is some good news I'm pleased
to say that the market has changed quite
significantly and for the first time
since the start of the gas crisis we are
seeing downward pressure on prices
now I've expressed of many committees
the Deep uncertainty and projections and
indeed if you look at six thousand
Pounds versus where we are today you can
see how much variability there is in the
market but we do expect on existing
projections that the price guarantee
will be breached by the price cap in
July and indeed that means Bills going
down for customers and significantly
reduces the fiscal cost of the price
guarantee in the first place
now um in thinking more broadly about
the retail Market I just want to focus
on three things so first of all
standards of service
so we have carried out a series of
compliance reviews we have moved from
being a reactive regulator that used to
respond to individual complaints and try
and resolve them to one that is looking
across the market and I think our
message to the sector has been really
clear we need to see standards improve
particularly for the most vulnerable so
last year we ran a review and we asked
every company to demonstrate how they
were going to improve their approach to
more vulnerable customers and I'm happy
to expand on what we found and why we
came to that conclusion equally you know
we have run reviews on Direct debits we
have rung reviews on treatment of
customers in affordability issues and
indeed we will continue to do so now I'm
not pretending these reviews are perfect
they're a very different way of
regulating we're moving into conduct
regulation as opposed to more reactive
compliance regulation we had before but
in my mind those are fundamental to make
sure we unearth first and then drive up
the standards we see in the industry
second touching on financial resilience
you know the committee and indeed all of
us examined really carefully what
happened in 2021 and I am pleased to say
the sector is in a more financial
resilient position today than it was
when the crisis started so we have seen
dramatic changes in the market over the
course of winter with gas prices being
10 15 times their normal price at six
pounds a firm and we haven't seen a
major failure to date
that said the sector does need to
recapitalize so using the powers we have
today plus the new rules that we are
putting in place we intend to make sure
that happens and then finally and I
think this was mentioned earlier the
future of pricing regulation and are
thinking around what that might mean now
the price cap has done a good job for
customers overall particularly when the
market was stable but we we believe that
it has costs as well as benefits so
coming on to the question of how we
might sort of evolve the market we do
think there is a case for examining more
flexible pricing regulation that allows
companies in the market to adapt more
quickly to the circumstances around them
but we think that would need to be
accompanied by more thinking around how
you support vulnerable customers and
I've said publicly we think a serious
examination of a social tariff funded
progressively is a way in which we might
be able to tackle some of the issues
really that are the root cause of what
customers highlighted today the last
thing I would say and I think this came
up in the last session we do need to
focus on the issues being raised in the
non-domestic in the business sector as
well as by domestic customers so we have
a series of reviews underway to look at
behavior in that part of the market as
well as a domestic Market thank you and
we'll touch on some of those points
today just one final question for me
um you've come to the committee
previously and we've talked about cust
uh businesses going bust because of
market conditions are you worried now
that businesses will voluntarily close
down their operations because they just
don't think it's a viable business for
them anymore whether it be further
consolidation in the number of energy
suppliers well I think that's possible
so when I talked to many of the people
who own businesses and you saw the
announcement of the review by shell for
example it remains a concern to us
around the long-term sustainability and
attractiveness of this market now we
will continue to do what we can in two
ways both in terms of evolving the
existing price cap to make sure it's as
flexible as possible given some of the
trade-offs there with customers
themselves but also as we build
Financial resilience in the sector I
think it will become more compelling for
investors to come into this market and
make sure they can see a sustained
profit and not one that's simply based
on the volatility in the market thank
you Alan Brown please yeah thanks here
um
just now 10 Christ 8.4 million come
April and certain advice estimators two
million households self-disconnecting at
least once a month and we've seen a
massive increase in customers been
fortunate prepayment meters
which of James assessment is as bad as
these figures
so you know when you step back from all
of this and you look at the market as a
whole
without a doubt given the the price
guarantee at two and a half thousand
pounds a year despite unprecedented
support from government in this sector
there are many families who are facing a
basic problem of affordability so I
thought that Jillian sort of outlined it
really well you know I've sat in and
spoken to customers where they work out
their budgets and those budgets are
negative now the question really
underneath all of this is how do we
within the market indeed within wider
policy want to address that issue and
one password you agree with these the
skill the problem what you know over 8
million households organic fuel poverty
come April I think there's you know two
million are self-disconnected and once a
month that is how to start reality of
the position so we certainly accept that
the scale of the problem is very large I
mean there's lots of definitions of fuel
poverty and how you might address it but
fundamentally there are many people who
have serious issues with affording their
energy today
okay so once when self-dest connection
so someday can't afford to put money in
their meter
the
choose a note to use energy but actually
build up their standing charges which
makes it even more difficult for them to
ever turn the heating back on
is that just that someday not accessing
their energy bows up dead before they
can you know the prohibits come from
getting you know being able to hit the
home again yeah look we looked at the
issue of standing charges last year and
we looked at how we were going to
socialize the costs of the levy for
example as part of that and we'll
continue to examine the right balance
between standing charges and more
variable charges
what that review uncovered though was
actually by moving more of the cost onto
variable charges there are another set
of customers who are significantly
harmed so for example if you're a
disabled family if you're a family that
has someone who depends on electricity
that uses a lot of electricity you were
made quite significantly worse off
versus some of the benefits of those who
were in the normal average situation
about targeted support line to help the
disabled so my view with all of this is
that if underneath all of these
questions is a question of affordability
and that's what we need to focus on so
coming back to the idea of a social
tariff if you had a social tariff if
that were funded in a way that wasn't
socializing that cost on other
low-income families then that'd be a way
to tackle the fundamental problem which
is however you structure the charges
there are families who are struggling to
pay
and in this second standing charges
people in prepayment meters pay a higher
standing charge you've defended that
before saying well of course the energy
companies more
oh Lord as hard keyboards cost them more
when they can go
um
smart meter prepayment modes so
companies are actually getting money up
front from these vulnerable customers so
again is it just the people in
prepayment mode pay higher standing
charges and the government says it's
pure La matter for off terms so is it
purely enough James gift
to ascertain that it's just that these
people pay more in prepayment mode so we
we have had the principle that we
reflect the costs that it that suppliers
face when they're supplying energy and
our best estimate the cost is is that
it's slightly higher for prepayment
meters but we are currently looking at
that and we are examining whether there
is a case for a cross-subsidy within the
industry that will equalize some of the
costs between payment methods now I
don't want to over promise on that
because it's complex and that you would
need transfers between companies so for
example we have companies in the market
that just have prepayment with customers
if it is it is reasonable and we think
that it is that a levelized sort of
price would mean they weren't able to
recover their cost we'd have to find
some way to make that good and it's that
complexity that we're working with at
the moment what was your time frame
given that you agree
he seemed a broadly agree you know near
I thought the households in few poverty
so it's a time frame for archery
resolving these matters and that will
take some time I don't know if you want
to come on specifically at the time but
it's something that would need to take
months rather than weeks I absolutely
agree it's a month's not not week's
issue and it is really complex um and
there'll be a lot of debate about that
issue because we have to understand when
we take that decision who those winners
and losers are and if we don't we're not
acting rationally as a regulator and I
am concerned that we we will put some
some elements of society in severe
difficulty by undertaking that change we
have to consider it in the round
equal the longer we wait more people are
forced on the prepayment mode and
therefore paying these higher charges
yeah and I think I'll come back to that
point though that I sat in front of this
committee I think in May last year and
we talked about the standing charge and
how we apply the solar Levy and I said
then we were looking at changing it and
quite frankly I was in almost 98
expectation that we would make the
change the analysis showed us that
prepayment meter customers in general
were made slightly worse off by doing
that rather than better off so all we
are saying is that these are complex
issues and when you make a cross subsidy
when you make a transfer that creates
winners and losers and that's what we
need to look at in detail
I find that surprising but I like
yourself too thank you
last week you announced a review on
self-dest connection remote switching
and forced installations and the checks
and balances around a decision to put
customers on a prepayment meter and that
we've heard widespread reports of
vulnerable customers being forced on the
prepayment meters for some time why is
it taking until now after the Secretary
of State Road to supplies for you to
respond you've already completed the
market
compliance review looking at whether
supplies are adhering to their license
conditions why is this going to be any
different
well if you go back and look at the
middle of last year and the sorts of
concerns we were being raised the first
thing we focused on was more broadly how
vulnerable customers are treated so that
mandatory change to a prepayment meter
is something that happens at the end of
a process so the first question you want
to ask a supplier is what are you doing
when a company is in when a customer's
in financial distress to find out their
circumstances to identify their
vulnerabilities and to make sure you
tailor your response towards that and
that review found that every company
needs to make improvements what we're
doing with this review is looking very
precisely at the moment of prepayment
meter is enforced into someone's home or
indeed the switch over in the smart
meter is forced in someone's home to
make sure those checks and balances are
also being followed if I were to
describe and Neil may want to expand on
this what I think we found overall is
principally a lack of consistency within
companies so quite often you are relying
on the person that you call and the
quality of the person that you call to
make sure that the systems and processes
and governance are being isolate and
quite often that's not the case this is
advice called for a ban on the forced
installation of pre-permanent meters
until these supports are in place and we
can be confident about it would you
support that or is it going to cause
problems for energy supplies and
recovering debt well I mean we sat with
with you with Charities we've sat with
the companies themselves and we've tried
to get under the skin of what we should
do here
now there is something I will say that
may not be popular here but there are a
group of customers who can afford to pay
their bills who choose not to and so
everyone has agreed in those
circumstances the mandatory switch to a
prepayment meter is a reasonable
response to families who can afford to
pay the question is how you identify a
vulnerable group of customers and how
you protect against those who face much
more significant risks when you make
that kind of decision and so we think
the right thing to do first of all we
think so far the rules are there they
are in place we will make sure through a
detailed review that we assess whether
they've been adequately followed whether
the transition to a prepayment meter
genuinely is a last resort and we will
use enforcement action if we need to and
the one thing I welcome but Emma's
comments is that we will be enforcing
aggressively if we find that companies
have not followed the right systems and
processes in treating their customers
but in terms of what's good for the
industry in terms of the fact that we
are seeing bad debt increase
significantly which ultimately every
customer pays for we need to get a
balance here we think principally this
is a compliance issue if we find the
rules changing but then we'll change the
rules and can I just add to that if I
may around the scope of the review
because I think that's really important
it's about the journey so it's not
acceptable that people are finding this
a surprise yes a remote switch to a
prepayment meter or somebody turning on
the door there should be multiple
contacts in that Journey so we are going
to make sure that we do sample checking
of proper of the customers that have
been affected actually look at that
issue in detail and come up with the
facts to enable us to take action it
also opens up a debate around toughening
up our rules or changing our rules to be
more prescriptive and again we have to
think about the balance of that around
you know creating a rule book that's
hundreds of pages long and difficult to
enforce versus the principles that are
in here at the moment but we welcome
that debate our role is to make sure
that we do Drive the standards up and
this is this is clearly an issued and
needs to be looked at but in terms of
driving standards up we're hearing
stories of direct debits being increased
and supplies sitting on cash
um uh on on fairly uh what is happening
in that space what action is being taken
to make sure that doesn't happen I think
there's quite a positive story about the
compliance review and its impact as part
of that but Neil perhaps you haven't
expanded yeah absolutely so the
compliance reviews are about driving
those standards up as I've talked about
so we did the direct debit review we
agreed with all suppliers there are
Improvement plans we've checked off
those those actions 50 or 56 are
complete which means the standards for
direct debits are improving across the
industry and 11 out of 16 audits that
suppliers agreed to commit to have been
also been completed so we have the fact
base that we worked on we've drove the
processes that's the training of all of
the agents across the across the
industry that's the controls in place
over direct debits that's the outcomes
for customers the management information
being reviewed the governance that
exists over the process and will
continue to go through our monitoring
data and re-review that to make sure
that those direct debits that are
increasing are just and you will
occasion see an odd direct debit
increase we know that that happens if
there's a there's an issue with a meter
or there's no underlying issue in in in
something in the system but what we're
saying is if that's uncovered you know
it should be clear clearly explained to
a customer it should be clearly
understood about why that director is
increasing and the result of our review
I think we've seen improvements over
that over that uh over that review so
I'll just stress again one more thing
that this is not just a point in time
we're just going to look at direct
debits at once this is an ongoing
process it's a strategic process to go
through customer Journeys on a regular
basis again our supplier sitting on on
on deposits and hoarding cash that
doesn't be a lot that doesn't belong to
them that's a question I'm asking I'm is
that is it happening and if so on what
sort of scale we don't think think so
and I'm happy to write to the committee
with regards to the the value of cash
that's held in on customer accounts as a
result of direct debits recognizing
there's a cycle throughout the year so I
think that's the important thing to know
is the the industry is likely to be
building up customer deposits through
summer those deposits are built up till
sort of October November of those I use
to pay for energy in Winter because most
customers prefer to have their direct
debits fixed monthly as a monthly
payment across the year and we all use
much less energy in summer than in
Winter what we don't think we're seeing
systemically is credit balancing is
being built up in the way that we saw
pre-2021 but we will keep that under
review
thank you just very quickly Jonathan you
said there were some customers that can
afford to pay but won't pay and that was
part of the rationale for some of the
actions energy companies are taking on
debt collection how can you possibly
know that's the case
so I think we have we've had this
problem in the industry for a number of
years in the sense that this is an issue
about how you manage your bad debt so if
you look back over a normal year for
example around 20 percent of mandatory
enforcement installation of normal
prepayment meters is about the normal
rate you again about 20 less than we've
seen last year so throughout the process
there are always case studies of
customers who are able to pay and we the
only argument I'm making here is if that
is the case then we think that an
installation of a prepayment meter is a
reasonable response the balance of
what's happened is something that we
need to uncover during the review and
that's what we'll be doing the thing I'm
struggling with is that if the Russian
Alpha forced installment of a prepayment
meter is based on a case study or an
assumption you can't actually know can
you don't have access to people's
incomes and outgoings you don't know if
people can afford or not to pay their
energy bills and I would assume and
again this is an assumption that most
people that aren't paying their bills is
because they can't afford to pay them so
do you see the point I'm trying to make
I struggled with the idea that you would
allow forced installation of
pre-permanent meters because there have
been case studies in the past where some
people can pay but don't
so I going back to what offgen can do so
this the rights to do this ultimately is
protected by law so requires a change in
the law to move away from that so
suppliers can install a meter and that
set out in the energy act the the simple
point I'm making and it's a very simple
point which is if you have let me put it
this way if you have a customer who is
able to pay and chooses not to then I
believe this is a reasonable response
for a supplier that has to manage its
bad debt and has to manage its own
financial situation indeed is obliged to
do so now the balance of how many
customers there are in the market who
are like that is something we'll uncover
in the review but if you look back over
a number of years this has been a
response that suppliers have had and I
think from the evidence I've seen from
from the discussions we've had indeed
with consumer groups that you know those
customers exist and if they do exist
this feels like a reasonable response
what we can't do and your right chair is
say out of the households we've seen
last year if there is X percent that we
know can afford their bills and why
percent they don't but that's part of
what we'll be testing okay thank you
Ruth Edwards please thank you chair how
would you describe the culture in the
energy industry going back to the
comments earlier from energy UK so
um
so honestly I'm quite disappointed by
the comments that we had today and it
feels like a step backwards
um I think I came in in 2021 and I I
explained sort of Express concerns about
not only the culture but the
relationship with the retail business
and with the regulator and with
government now I think we've made a lot
of progress over the last year and a
half where all of us have had to work
together collaboratively to solve a
whole set of problems you know how we're
going to evolve pricing regulation how
are we going to design Financial
regulation that does move the market to
a better place and indeed how do we
address some of the issues around
customer standards what concerns me is
if the industry's answer is genuinely
well the regulation should force us to
look after vulnerable customers then
there is still a long way to go before
we get the right culture in this part of
the industry and from your experience as
the regulator is that something is do
you think that's a fair assessment of
the culture in the industry or not so I
personally I I think that is not a good
representation of where the industry is
but the fact that the trade body is
putting it that way deeply concerns me
thank you
um the nguk also criticized some of the
criteria you used in your Market
compliance reviews
um what's your response to that
well if the committee will indulge me
I'll just describe the normal process
when we go through enforcement so it's
almost like the stages of grief so the
first stage is you've got your facts
wrong the second stage is well everybody
else is doing it then the third stage is
well the harm wasn't that bad so quite
frankly I think that energy UK are on
the first stage now it's not to say that
our methodology is perfect these are
quite new and quite fundamental changes
to the way that we regulate but the
truth is you know the complaints always
come when you find someone in their
seriously unsatisfactory category and
that's where usually your methodology is
questioned if I had a kind of comment on
on what I've seen and Neil and I are
debating this and he may disagree
actually I do think we need to think
about how we adapt to the different
business models that are in the market
so when you're looking at governance
processes and you are looking at the way
in which companies approach things there
is a risk you go for a more traditional
assessment rather than being broader for
the newer companies that are in the
market so one of the things we're
exploring is how do we get a more
outcome focused approach to the
compliance review
I'd certainly like the approach to
evolve to take into account other
people's views around the service
metrics as part of the assessment and I
think we have to really really get
better at that sampling methodology I
think we need to get better at kind of
the analyst analytics around the data
that's all available and we're making
improvements we are bringing in
individuals into those teams to do that
but this would be an ongoing process and
if we can get that all working correctly
then the service standards do improve
over all suppliers will be in a much
better space but I appreciate it does
take time thank you
um we've been discussing higher prices
paid by customers on prepayment meters
but I also we've also been told that
customers paying by cash or check pay up
to 254 pounds more a year than customers
on a direct debit
um do you think this is is Justified I I
appreciate it's a more expensive way of
paying but it does seem to be a huge
premium
so again Neil will expand on this we are
concerned about the way the the
methodology has evolved and part of the
methodology for standard credit
customers does scale with the cost of
energy but what we want to do is look
across all payment methods and see
whether there is a case for leveling
them but as I say that there are
trade-offs there first of all the
complexity of some companies having to
pay other companies for
um who have different proportions of
different kinds of customers and
secondly we need to remember the
incentive effects here so originally
when these differentials were made part
of that was encouraging people onto
direct debits but I think personally
we're at the limit point where actually
if you are on standard credit it is
unlikely that you're going to move to
another form of payment because it
simply is part of the way you manage
your budgets and and the way you want to
run your life I suppose my concern is
that a lot of older customers also might
be paying for example by check I mean to
me 254 pounds sounds like a really
nosebleed price for that that difference
what's your view Neil
so yeah absolutely you understand there
is a proportion of society that um that
do choose cash check and they have a
belief that that's the way you should do
things there's been a lot of work in the
industry to try and encourage
um
to try and correct the belief that
that's a good way of managing your money
if you can afford to go on Direct debit
it's cheaper and to kind of get that
that set of customers particularly to
migrate to that smart world where
there's more protections you know in
place I think we could go further in
that space we could look more at what
companies can do to incentivize and
ultimately we need to have a look at the
underlying cost models but it is complex
there are industry charges in those in
in those in in those different um
product types that that differ they're
also different debt levels that need to
be cross-subsidized so it's a really
complicated change to make and
Jonathan's right it could involve cross
subsidization across companies which
will be really really complex to
implement and it won't be a short it
won't be a short fix you think you're
likely to persuade older customers who
perhaps don't use the internet to go on
to a direct debit payment
I think the point I would make is that
that's why we think we're at the limit
of worrying about the incentive effects
because we're at the limit of in a sense
the number of people who would now make
that transition which is why it feels
right to us to have a look across all
payment methods and see whether they
should be equalized
come on
um did I
did I understand right from your opening
comments that expect the price cut come
down in July so we expect the price cap
to be below the level the new level of
the energy price guarantee which is 3
000 pounds in July so we are seeing the
first signs perhaps of the market easing
and I think a lot of people find it
difficult to understand why when the
price starts the wholesale price starts
to rise the energy price cap goes up
very quickly but when the wholesale
price has fallen it seems to take many
many months to filter through to con to
Consumers
um can you just set out why that is I'm
really happy too that the formula we use
for the price cap is is is fixed you
know it changes a little bit but it's
probably the same so the truth is the
price cap didn't rise when the market
prices first rise in fact there was
almost a six month delay before prices
went up now what it does is it says the
best way to manage risk is to ask
companies to buy forward to buy energy
in the market for three months or six
months time well that does mean is when
price is full it takes three to six
months for that to unwind to go back
into to customers bills so there are
small changes to the formula but the
formula going up is exactly the same as
a formula coming down and importantly
when The Crisis began and the gas prices
started Rising we had a six-month price
cap formula so the lag was actually six
to eight months and through the crisis
to make the price cap actually more
resilient in the face of this volatility
we we compressed that and it's now a
quarterly price cap there are lead times
but it's not cost of three or four
months lead time so prices will fall for
consumers if market prices stay at the
sort of levels that they're coming down
to now thank you thank you very much
we've only got about 10 minutes left so
about five minutes each so Ian Lavery
please
um I think it's fair to share that of
dream support to the introduction of it
a social tariff
oh just to clarify just just just
um and I'm just wondering whether I
could tell the select committee if you
work with a government with regards to a
a social tariff
if you're what what do you think the
design possibly could be and are you
looking towards specific individuals
being targeted
so
um just stepping back from all of this
we we do think there is Merit in looking
at her social tariff we haven't done all
the detailed work behind it that you'd
need to do or indeed traded it off
against other interventions the
government might be contemplating such
as changes to benefits and other ways of
supporting vulnerable customers but just
to expand a bit on why that is the case
so why would you go for a price-based
intervention rather than one sort of
driven by fiscal decisions and and what
you normally do when you're concerned
about
families in poverty across the country
and the reason for me is that even
though benefits can be uprated by
inflation the difference in the scale of
energy use between two different
households in basically the same income
circumstances can be very large so if
you're living in a well-insulated flat
with a family of three in modern housing
that that is well equipped your energy
bill is fundamentally different from a
family in drafty poor energy efficient
social housing who have other Engineers
such as disabled children now the only
way I can see of making sure that the
support matches that difference is to
have something that intervenes in the
price that those customers pay and
that's why we think you know if you are
going to think about the future of
pricing regulation and I agree almost
with the question that was asked in the
last session around pricing regulation
we think broadly for most customers at
least something that is more flexible
and more adaptable it's right to focus
on the affordability issue which is
ultimately goes beyond regulation to
something that is subsidized in terms of
the design I think
in principle I support what citizens
advice was suggesting about the way you
might do it the thing I would like to
see and this is a big challenge is
making sure that those customers who
receive a social tariff don't miss out
on the new world that we're hoping comes
into place so Emma mentioned that you
know the flexibility in initiatives for
example where many of us will be turning
off our lights and using less energy
between five and six this is the sort of
world we're moving to and I would like a
system whereby the most vulnerable
customers can absolutely benefit from
that kind of future for the retail
market in terms of who's targeted I mean
that's a massive question my startup
attend but it's no more than that it's a
personal start of a 10 rather than a big
sort of off-chem sort of detail piece of
work is you probably need to attach it
to some other existing indicator of
income which means looking particularly
at those who are receiving benefits but
all of that is Up For Debate and all of
that is something that I think we need
to work through
should replace the existing price cup
and if there was a social tariff how
quickly do you think it could be
implemented
so I think we need to think seriously
about the cost and the benefits and the
price cap for customers today so it has
done a good job particularly when the
market was stable but just to explain
why we think it has costs for customers
you have a fixed price for everybody and
you have a volatile Market the only
thing we can do as a regulator to make
sure that we don't see a repeat of 2021
is to ask companies to hold
significantly more Capital now if they
hold more Capital they hold more money
within the company ultimately that needs
to pay someone a return otherwise that
that Capital simply won't be invested
and that costs customers money so the
trade-off we've got to make between the
price cap and the Alternatives is
whether those costs are beginning to
outweigh the benefit the second thing
I'd say and probably one of the least
popular things often has done is
introduced the market stabilization
charge which is the charge between
different suppliers when someone moves
from one to the other certainly at times
like now where you see where you see
prices Falling Again these are secondary
and tertiary impacts of the price cap
they're important to assess to make sure
you can look at the Alternatives when I
look at the Alternatives you can go
right the way from going back to focus
on pricing Behavior so something like
you do in the insurance market so
preventing the is called the acquisition
Towers so it was called bait and switch
where a company would give you a low
offer free year but slowly transition
you to a much higher price right the way
through to things like relative price
caps which are a bit more adaptable to
the market that's in place but I think
if you do that then you have to address
the affordability issues and ultimately
for me that means seriously examining a
social tariff
quickly how quickly could a tariff be
implemented well you know I think that
there's a lot of detailed work that
needs to be done to answer that question
all I'd say is the energy price
guarantee was implemented in a matter of
weeks and months so you know we need to
work with government and it needs to be
urgent thanks thank you very much Mark
Posey Please Mr really you told us what
you thought about Emma pinchbeck's
evidence what did you make of what uh
Kate had to say in UK hospitality and
alarmingly this business that if
Hospitality SEC company went out to get
six quotes four people wouldn't bother
so I think this is a real substantive
issue and she mentioned what we did in
November to begin to start to address it
um
I think you've got to look at both sides
of this though so if you go back into
the market say in August you have prices
at six pounds a firm it was incredibly
hard for any retailer to genuinely be
able to hedge a contract that they were
passing through at a fixed price to a
business customer so what we've got to
unpack is really two big things that I
think are of concern to us the first is
around whether or not companies abuse
the fact that other companies weren't
offering tariffs and so simply jacked up
their prices the sub companies abused
the fact that they can demand huge
upfront payments right I mean all of
that needs to be looked at and simply
say if you're in a market you know your
competitors aren't bidding then you'll
behave in a different way and we need to
frankly see whether there was Market
abuse at that time do you think you've
got enough Powers currently to get
involved in that sector or would you
like to see an extension of your powers
to regulate the supply to non-domestic
customs well we already regulate What's
called the deemed rate which is almost
the rate you're put on if flyer doesn't
offer you a fixed tariff and that is
something that we're reviewing and we're
looking at the question as to whether we
need more Powers is is more broadly
where so one thing I would be cautious
about I'm not saying we're completely
against it and we need to do the work
with the treasury to assess this but I'd
be cautious about further pricing
regulation in the market until we have
something that works arguably haven't
you got enough on your plate already
without says because standard prows into
this sector yeah we have we have plenty
on our plate now the question really is
has the behavior of the company's really
okay and you're part of your role is to
protect vulnerable customers shouldn't
we say that you know uh tough business
people should be able to deal with that
all of these issues themselves why do
they need you to get involved so that's
the framing I think the piece that I
think we need to look at is micro
businesses and small and medium-sized
Enterprises where there is a case for
that but we've had this conversation
again we debate all this within the
building there is a risk if you continue
to regulate for every problem that you
see on behalf of a customer you end up
with a much bigger robot than the one
you have today all right thank you thank
you to to last very quick questions and
answers one if the energy companies are
not making any profit how easy is it for
them to capitalize their business to the
levels you need
so this is the ongoing kind of iteration
of pricing regulation that we need to
make so if you look at what happened
last year where I think sort of quarter
three I think the companies many
companies were on track to make a profit
for that year but simply because of the
warm winter and the low prices in the
market many of them are unable to do so
and again it comes back to chair the
interaction of the price Gap with the
market that we're seeing now we will
adapt to that so we will pass through
reasonable costs when we iterate the
price cap next time and we have done
previously and I'd argue we have a good
reputation with the industry for doing
that but ultimately this will come down
to whether or not you need to put more
into the price cap to raise prices for
customers to offset some of these risks
and that's why we're saying perhaps
pricing regulation in this way is to
regulate too rigid for the sort of
Market we have today and lastly you said
earlier that a social tariff should be
funded progressively does that mean your
personal view is it should be funded by
General taxation you know I'm teaching
on the brink of off gems job here but I
what I struggle to see is that a social
to have been funded by other people's
bills so we've done the analysis we've
looked at it as a board and it is very
hard to see how you would charge quite
significantly more to a customer say on
eighteen thousand a year to fund a
customer who's on 14 000 a year through
a series of benefits and so to me if
you're going to provide support it's
best done progressively okay we could
keep going but I'm afraid we've timed
out so we'll no doubt see you again
later in the uh thank you to all three
of you for your contributions today
thank you for members to keeping us to
time our conversation out to an end
order order
the proceeding has ended